You know, there's that saying,
the one that gets pulled out in
basically any conversation about
conflict.
Oh, I know exactly which one you
mean.
We've all used it.
Yeah, one man's freedom fighter
is another man's terrorist.
Exactly.
And it's it's sort of the
perfect conversation under,
isn't it?
It's this neat little
philosophical shrug.
It lets us acknowledge that
things are complicated and then,
you know, just move on without
getting our hands dirty.
Right.
It's a weighted gesture and
moral ambiguity.
But the the stack of sources
we've been digging into for this
deep dive, they make a really
provocative argument.
They say it's not just some
clever paradox.
No, not at all.
They call it a blunt operational
truth.
A blunt operational truth.
And what they mean by that is
that the phrase doesn't just
describe a feeling or a point of
view.
It actually reveals the literal
visible architecture of how
power works, how it's won, how
it's lost, and how it's
maintained.
And I think that's really our
mission for you today.
We're going to try and unpack
that architecture.
We're stepping away from the
comfortable moral certainties
and looking at material that
suggests legitimacy isn't some
fixed heavenly category.
Yeah, negotiated.
It's totally negotiated.
It's a high stakes negotiation
and the currency isn't abstract
morality, it's practical things.
It's hunger, it's humiliation,
it's the need for vengeance, and
maybe most importantly, it's
just pure, raw opportunity.
So the core idea right from the
jump is that if you stop looking
at legitimacy as this absolute
good versus evil thing and start
seeing it as a, well, a
practical contest for loyalty
and resources.
Then the whole geometry of power
just snaps into focus.
You can see it clearly.
And the sources warn us, seeing
that geometry, really seeing it
can be, and I'm quoting here,
deeply uncomfortable.
It is because it's messy.
It forces you to look at
governance itself as something
transactional.
The sources are pretty clear.
When a formal government fails
to provide for its people,
whether that's through
corruption or just incompetence,
a vacuum is created.
And something always fills a
vacuum.
Always.
And the things that fill it,
they almost always involve 2 key
ingredients, cash and guns.
So our goal today is to analyze
how that vacuum gets filled and,
crucially, how language is used
to either, you know, sanitize or
demonize whoever steps in to
fill it.
OK, so let's get into that.
Let's unpack this architectural
analysis using the example the
material offers up as the
simplest but also the most
volatile.
The most radioactive one?
Yeah.
The global War on Terror, it
really does bring all these
definitions into sharp relief.
It's the perfect starting point
because when you look at
conflicts like Iraq or
Afghanistan through this
particular lens, all of our
standard comfortable definitions
like combatant and civilian,
they just immediately start to
destabilize.
They really do.
I mean, the analysis we reviewed
makes this one observation that
is so stark you really have to
just stop and sit with it for a
second.
Says that by the strict legal
definitions of warfare, you know
the Geneva Conventions, rules
about state uniforms, ranks,
formal armies.
The rules of the game, so to
speak.
Exactly.
By those rules, every single
person America and its allies
killed in that war was
technically a civilian.
And that's a statement that just
sounds wrong on 1st hearing,
doesn't it?
But it demands you look closer.
We're so conditioned to think of
war as state versus state to
armies in different colored
uniforms meeting on a field.
Right, but that's not what this
was.
You had individuals who for a
whole spectrum of reasons,
ideology, desperation, money,
revenge, chose to pick up a
weapon.
They chose to, yeah.
They weren't conscripted into
the Iraqi National Army.
They were, you know, farmers,
shopkeepers, engineers who
joined a faction.
They joined something else, and
you can see the intervening
powers struggling with what do
you even call them?
Are they insurgents, Extremists,
Foreign fighters?
Militia.
Narco terrorists.
The label kept shifting.
But their fundamental status
didn't.
They were non state actors.
They were operating completely
outside the traditional
framework of recognized nation
state armies.
And here's the other side of
that coin, the chilling
distinction the source material
makes the people sent to kill
them.
Yeah, they were the complete
opposite.
They weren't civilians at all.
They were the most professional,
state sanctioned, highly trained
killers that the modern world
has ever produced.
We're talking JSOC teams, Navy
Seals, Delta Force, Marine
Raiders, the British S, S and
SBS.
And you have to include the
drone crews, people sitting in a
container in Nevada operating
with the full legal backing and
protection of a superpower
state.
So you have these professional
state soldiers, paid and
protected by their governments,
sent to hunt and kill people who
are by definition, civilians.
Civilians who lack any of those
state protections, but whom the
state has conveniently relabeled
as enemy combatants to, you
know, make the whole thing
legally possible.
And that right there is the
anatomy of modern conflict.
When you strip it down to its
operational parts, it's not 2
armies fighting, it's one very
powerful state army facing what
the analysis calls a distributed
ecology of grievance, ideology,
desperation and opportunity.
That's such a great phrase, an
ecology of grievance.
It is because it's not a
monolith.
It's a multi headed,
decentralized, constantly
shifting reaction to a
catastrophic failure of local
governance.
Which brings us to the role of
language.
Because you can't fight in
ecology with traditional
military terms, so you have to
invent new ones.
Language itself becomes a tool,
a weapon even.
It becomes a tool of
categorization.
The sources call it language
triage.
Language triage.
I like that.
Yeah, it's the idea that
violence is sorted and labeled
based on one simple metric.
Who is wielding it and whose
interests does it serve?
So it's not about the ACT
itself, it's about the actor.
Precisely.
And I think it's worth walking
through the examples they give
because it makes the mechanism
so clear.
If we can for just a moment step
back from the gut level moral
reaction and just look at the
raw action and the label that
are recognized, layer one
authority would apply to it.
OK, let's do it.
Scenario 1A Civilian walks into
a crowded market and detonates a
bomb.
The intent is to kill other
civilians for a political cause.
The label is immediate, it's
universal.
That is terrorism, no debate.
The ACT is civilian on civilian
violence.
OK.
Now same person, different
scenario.
He doesn't go to the market.
Instead, he takes a rifle and
fires at a foreign military
patrol that's rolling through
his neighborhood.
A patrol that, let's say, just
last week, bulldozed his
cousin's farm to clear a line of
sight.
Suddenly the language shifts.
The state aligned media, the
military press briefings don't
call it terrorism anymore.
Now it's insurgency, maybe
rebellion.
The ACT is still a civilian
attacking people with guns, but
the target has changed.
The target has changed, and the
motive is now framed as
grievance, not just pure
ideology.
It's seen as an attempt to fight
a state actor, not terrorize a
population.
The label changes the moral
weight of the ACT.
And it gets even messier, right?
Way messier.
OK, so picture a group of local
guys.
They set up an illegal
checkpoint on a key smuggling
Rd.
They've got guns and they're
forcing every truck that passes
to pay a tax.
So armed robbery, extortion.
Well, it depends.
If that checkpoint is, say,
Prime, disrupting A rival
smuggling group that happens to
be an enemy of the new Layer 1
government, then the state might
just look the other way.
So they tolerate.
It they might even quietly
support it.
And in the official reports it
gets called militia activity.
It's framed as a sort of local
self policing initiative, a
tolerable parallel authority.
But if that same checkpoint
starts taxing, say, government
supply convoys or harassing
officials loyal to the capital?
The label flips overnight,
instantly.
It's no longer militia activity.
Now it's extremist violence.
It's an organized criminal
enterprise.
The underlying action, illegal
taxation enforced by the barrel
of a gun, is identical, but its
relationship to the state's
interest determines its name.
And then there's the state's own
violence, the final piece of the
triage.
Right when the state or its
layer three foreign ally wants
to kill one specific person in a
house and to do that they drop a
£500 guided bomb on that house
knowing it's full of his family
and neighbors.
That's never called violence
against civilians, even when
that's the literal outcome.
Never.
It's sanitized.
It's called a precision strike.
It's framed as a military
necessity.
The civilian deaths are always
always described as regrettable
but justified.
So the whole point of this
language triage, as the source
argues, is to manage our moral
dissonance, the public's
dissonance.
Exactly.
It's for us, the consumers of
the conflict narrative.
The language creates a
comfortable distance.
It allows us to see their
violence as barbaric and ours as
clinical.
It's a tool that lets the state
avoid, as the quote goes,
witnessing our own reflection in
the brutality of it all.
It's a way to maintain the
state's moral monopoly.
That's it.
It's a tool for power
projection.
And it explains why these cycles
of violence just keep going.
Because when you strip away the
labels, you see it's not a fight
between good and evil.
It's an ongoing, brutal
competition between competing
authorities.
Which leads us directly into the
core framework of this whole
analysis.
The reason that reflection is so
hard to escape.
The three layers of power.
This is the geometry.
It's the key to understanding
what happens when governance
fails, not just in war zones
but, as we'll see, everywhere.
And this isn't some abstract
political science theory.
The sources say this framework
came directly from people on the
ground, soldiers, diplomats,
journalists observing places
like Iraq or Somalia, places
that were existing on three
completely different operational
realities all at the same time.
Right.
It's a way to make sense of the
chaos.
So let's break them down.
We can start with the one that's
most visible to the outside
world.
Layer one, the official state.
This is the one we all
recognize.
It's the face of the country,
the ministries in the Capitol,
the police in their official
uniforms, the central bank
printing the currency.
It's the national anthem, the
flag flying over the
presidential palace, the
official forms you have to fill
out to get a permit.
It's the authority that has a
seat at the United Nations.
It's the official story of who
is in charge.
But in a lot of these places,
that official story, it's just
that it's actual power might not
extend beyond the capitals.
Ring Rd.
And that's a crucial point for
the average person living in a
remote province or even a
neglected urban neighborhood.
Their daily life, their actual
survival, is determined by a
completely different set of
rules and a different set of
rulers.
Which brings us to the second
layer.
Layer 2, the parallel authority.
This is the power structure that
actually governs the street.
This is the reality of
day-to-day life.
We're talking the powerful
tribal shakes, the influential
local clerics, the old families
who've controlled the water
rights or the food smuggling
routes for generations.
It's the people who actually get
things done.
Exactly.
They deal in immediate practical
needs.
If your son gets unjustly
arrested, you don't go to the
corrupt Layer 1 courthouse, you
go to the local Sheikh.
If you need to move goods safely
through a dangerous area, you
pay the local warlord their
phone call.
Their word matters infinitely
more than some stamped piece of
paper from a ministry official
you'll never meet.
And this layer is often ancient.
It existed long before the
current government, and it'll
probably exist long after.
It's deeply rooted in the
culture and the economy of the
place.
And then, particularly in the
last few decades, you have a
third massive force that crashes
into this dynamic.
Layer 3, the foreign power.
The external force This could be
a coalition of invading armies,
UN peacekeepers, a swarm of
international Ng OS, or even
just the intelligence agencies
of a powerful neighboring
country.
And your view of this layer is
entirely transactional, isn't
it?
Depends on what they mean for
you personally.
Completely.
Are they the ones handing out
lucrative reconstruction
contracts and paying salaries in
U.S. dollars?
Or are they the ones conducting
night raids, kicking down doors
and leaving you to write
eulogies for your family
members?
They can be a source of immense
opportunity or immense grief,
often at the same time.
The key here, and what the
sources stress, is that these
three layers don't exist
separately.
They're all operating in the
same space at the same time.
It's this constant, violent,
shifting triangulation of power.
And that framework is the only
way to understand the absolute
payouts that follows a major
foreign intervention, because
layer 3 doesn't just show up and
neatly replace layer one.
It shatters the whole ecosystem.
It completely destabilizes the
existing, even if it was brutal
and dysfunctional, equilibrium
between all three layers.
And this is where that idea of
the power vacuum comes in, when
a superpower, a layer 3 actor,
decides to just knock the legs
out from under an existing layer
one regime, say by invading and
removing a dictator.
The headline back home is tyrant
toppled.
Freedom reigns.
But the operational reality on
the ground, as the sources put
it, is the creation of a
massive, power rich vacuum.
And nature abhors a vacuum, but
politics abhors it even more.
And as we said, vacuums draw
opportunists.
The removal of the central layer
One authority does something
incredibly profound.
It unleashes layer 2.
All those local power Breakers,
the tribal leaders, the
smuggling bosses, the clerics
who are kept in check by the
dictator's secret police,
suddenly the boot is off their
neck.
And they're free to reconfigure
their ambitions.
They can expand.
They can compete.
The competition that follows is
this, this frantic, violent
scramble for power, the sources
say.
It's basically driven by three
distinct types of people who
rush into that.
Vacuum.
OK, what are they?
First you have the remnants of
the old regime, the generals,
the ministers, the party
loyalists who lost everything.
They are fighting desperately to
reclaim their lost power.
They often become the leaders of
the initial insurgency fighting
for restoration.
Then you have the second group.
The opportunists.
These are the people who were
always on the fringes of power
under the old regime, the rival
tribe, the exiled political
opponents, the ambitious local
governor who always wanted more.
They see the chaos as their one
big chance to finally grab The
Maine prize.
And the third group.
This one sounds like the most
unpredictable.
They're the wild cunt, the most
dangerous.
These are the men who, under the
old stable order, never in a
million years imagined they
could hold real power.
But now, with the old rules
gone, they see a path.
These are the people willing to
take.
And I'm quoting insane risks for
a shot at the top.
Because they have nothing to
lose.
Nothing to lose and everything
to gain.
Their ambition is what often
fuels the most radical, most
brutal factions.
And this chaotic, free for all
is the moment of creation.
It's where the new labels are
forged.
How you come out of that scrum
determines what history calls
you.
Exactly.
If your faction wins the street
fight in a key city, you might
consolidate enough power to
become part of the new layer 1.
You become the new police chief,
the new mayor.
If you lose and die, you become
a martyr to your cause.
And if you lose, the political
fight.
But keep your guns and your
followers.
You become the villain, the
terrorist, the criminal that the
new victorious layer one can now
point to as the source of all
the problems.
It's a deeply cynical but
operationally very clear
interpretation of how states are
born from violence.
The difference between a
founding father and a terrorist
leader in that moment can come
down to who won the first few
battles and who got to print the
official letterhead.
What's really, I think,
unsettling about this three
layer model is how, well, how
portable it is.
Once you see that geometry in a
place like Baghdad or Kabul, you
can't Unsee it.
You start to recognize the same
dynamic playing out in places we
would never ever call a conflict
zone.
That's the leap the sources
make, and it's a powerful one.
They argue that in America, for
example, we tend to talk about
our most challenged urban
environments, what the media
often calls inner cities, almost
exclusively in terms of moral
failure.
It's a problem of culture or
character or individual choices.
That's the standard narrative.
Right.
But if you apply this three
layer lens, the picture changes
completely.
You start to see these areas not
as moral failures, but as, and
this is a great quote,
predictable byproducts of
neglected demand and
concentrated opportunity.
It's a structural problem, not
just a moral 1.
So let's try to do that.
Let's map this geometry onto an
American city, say parts of
Chicago or Baltimore, or any
major city with deeply
entrenched poverty and a history
of state neglect.
The mapping is shockingly clean.
Let's start with layer one.
The official government.
That's easy.
It's the mayor giving a press
conference.
The City Council, The police
commissioner, The official court
system, The school board.
It's the state's monopoly on
power, at least on paper.
But in many of these
neighborhoods, that layer one
authority is thin.
It's present, but it's not
always seen as legitimate or
effective.
The police reviewed with
suspicion city services are slow
or non existent.
Which just like in a failed
state, creates it's a vacuum,
and that vacuum is filled by
layer 2, the parallel authority.
And in this context, that means
what?
The gangs.
It's the gangs, it's the
powerful neighborhood crews,
it's the shot callers who
control the local drug trade.
It's the informal power
structures that actually provide
order and aversion of justice
where layer one has failed.
They're the ones who really
determine how the street
operates, who gets to sell on
which corner, who provides
security for local businesses,
whose cousin gets a job as a
lookout.
They have a system.
It's a violent one, but it's a
system of order.
It is, and then you have the
external force layer 3, the
federal layer.
So the FBI?
The DEA.
Exactly.
The DEA, the FBI, ATF, Homeland
Security, These federal agencies
that roll into the city with
heavy tactical gear, often
operating with a mandate from
Washington DC, not from the
local City Hall.
They come in to disrupt the
local ecosystem.
And just like a foreign
intervention, their arrival can
be incredibly destabilizing.
They might take out a major
Layer 2 leader, a powerful gang
boss, but they don't fix the
underlying conditions.
Not at all.
They don't fix the poverty or
the lack of jobs that created
the vacuum in the 1st place.
So a new, often younger and more
violent Layer 2 actor just rises
up to take the old one's place.
The source material uses this
lens to look at a really hot
button political issue,
sanctuary cities.
Right, which is something we
usually debate in purely moral
or political terms.
The rhetoric is always about
compassion, about resisting
federal overreach, about local
sovereignty.
It's a political and a moral
statement.
But if you look at it
structurally, operationally, a
city declaring itself a
sanctuary is a layer one
authority making a very clear
statement about who gets to
police.
It's layer 2.
They're saying we'll handle
this, not you.
They're saying we, the local
government, believe we know how
to manage this community better
than you, the federal
government, do.
And the unspoken rationale
behind that is often incredibly
pragmatic.
That phrase from the source.
Better are devils than your
Angel.
Exactly.
The local police, the local
mayor.
They may know that certain
illicit economies are part of
the neighborhood survival, know
which grandmother is having her
rent paid by a nephew who's
involved in the local crew.
They understand the delicate,
complicated social fabric.
And they're afraid that a big
blunt layer three federal raid
will just tear that fabric to
pieces, causing more chaos and
harm than it prevents.
They know that simply
decapitating layer 2 without a
viable replacement doesn't
create a more oral paradise, it
creates a vacuum.
And that core lesson applies
just as much here as it does
anywhere else in an American
city, just like in a Middle
Eastern one.
That vacuum is where you find
the kids with no prospects, no
jobs, no hope from layer one.
And that's where they strap, as
the quote goes, ambition to
adrenaline and just see how far
they can get before they end up
in prison or dead.
The structural cycle is
identical whether the setting is
post war or just post
industrial.
Overlap you're describing it
leads us to what is, for me,
maybe the most provocative
comparison in the entire
analysis.
Yeah.
This is the one that really
challenges our categories.
That the war on drugs is
operationally and structurally
the same kind of fight as the
War on Terror.
Which is a staggering claim
because we are conditioned to
see them as completely different
things. 1 is a law enforcement
problem, the other is a national
security or military problem.
But the sources insist on the
comparison.
Why?
What's the common denominator?
The common denominator is that
both are fights against powerful
non state actors who have
successfully established a form
of parallel governance.
They're doing the state's job.
They are thriving precisely
where the formal state has
failed to meet the three most
basic needs of its citizens, to
feed them, to protect them and
to treat them with a baseline of
respect and dignity.
They are a response to neglected
demand.
And in meeting that demand,
these groups, whether you call
them a cartel or an insurgency,
they provide structure, and in
exchange for that structure,
they demand loyalty, obedience
and risk.
They become, in the words of the
source, the gods of small things
in their territory.
They are the ones who can
actually solve your immediate
life or death problems.
It's worth really spelling out
what those state functions are
that they provide, because this
is where that line between a
government and a criminal
enterprise gets incredibly
blurry.
OK, let's list them.
First, and maybe most important
is financial aid, social
welfare.
These organizations step in to
pay for rent, for a loved ones,
hospital bill for bail money.
They have the social safety net
when the official layer one net
has collapsed or was never there
to begin with.
So they're the emergency loan
office?
They're the emergency loan
office, the welfare office and
the bank all rolled into one
second.
They provide security and a
system of justice.
It might be brutal eye for an
eye justice, but it is swift,
predictable and effective.
And in a place where the
official police are seen as
corrupt, ineffective or an
occupying force, that Layer 2
justice might feel more
legitimate to the local
population.
It often does.
They provide neighborhood
security.
They provide a sense of
belonging.
They'll avenge wrongs done to
their members.
It's conditional, of course.
It's conditional on your
absolute loyalty, but it's a
guarantee.
And the third function.
Social structure and, crucially,
economic opportunity.
For a young person with no
father figure, no Community
Center and no path to a decent
job, a gang or a cartel offers a
fraternity.
It gives them an identity, a
purpose and a clear, albeit
dangerous, ladder to climb for
status and wealth.
So they're providing everything
a state is supposed to provide.
Every single function, Welfare,
justice, security, economic
mobility, a sense of identity,
But they do it, as the analysis
says, with the efficiency and
brutality of a business.
And in a community where the
legal layer one economy only
offers you and I'm quoting
lectures, paperwork and
starvation.
The illegal economy doesn't look
like a moral failure.
It looks like the only ladder
people are willing and able to
climb.
So that's how the perspective
shifts from the outside.
From the layer one perspective
of, say, the US government, a
cartel is a clear existential
threat to stability in the rule
of law.
Absolutely a multibillion dollar
criminal organization, but if
you are an individual living
inside that system with no other
options, the definition changes.
If you don't have a job, the
cartel is an employer.
If the police won't protect you,
the cartel is your insurance
policy.
If you have an idea for a small
business but no bank will give
you a loan, the cartel is your
source of venture capital.
The interest rates are just a
lot.
Higher and the penalties for
default are final, but the
function is the same, and this
is what blurs the lines into
that final, really uncomfortable
definition from the source.
One man's illegal militia is
another man's Volunteer Fire
Department, code enforcement and
welfare office wrapped into one.
Funded by cocaine, fentanyl,
extortion, or ideology, the
function is what commands the
loyalty.
The label applied by outsiders
is irrelevant to the person
whose life is being saved or
sustained by it.
This is the point in the
analysis where, as the sources
themselves point out, a lot of
people just get angry.
Yeah, there's a real resistance
to it.
The idea of a functional
similarity between a state and a
cartel or a soldier and a
terrorist, it feels like an
attack on our whole moral order.
It feels like sacrilege.
And why is that?
What's the root of that anger?
I think it's because we have a
deep, deep need for moral
tidiness.
We want our history and our
politics to be simple.
We need our villains to be pure
evil, you know, with the black
capes and the twirling
mustaches.
And we need our heroes to be
completely pure in both their
methods and their intentions.
But real history and any honest
analysis of power is just never
that clean.
It's never that clean, and the
source material confronts this
discomfort directly, using a
really difficult but necessary
historical example to show why
this Harrow Villain binary so
often fails.
They bring up the Nazi regime in
Germany.
They do, and the point is not to
excuse or mitigate anything.
The moral atrocity of the
Holocaust is absolute and non
negotiable.
We want to remember that regime
only for that.
But that's not the full picture
of how they achieved and
maintained power.
The analysis points out that the
very same regime also delivered
on promises that resonated
deeply with millions of ordinary
Germans.
They restored full employment
after the Great Depression.
They gave a sense of profound
national pride back to a
population that had been utterly
humiliated by the Treaty of
Versailles and ruined by
hyperinflation.
Again, that fact isn't offered
as a justification.
Not at all.
It's offered as a complication.
It forces us to accept that
legitimacy is a complex and
dangerous thing.
People will support a
government, even a monstrous
one, for reasons that are
practical, emotional and
sometimes horrifying, often all
at once.
It complicates the idea that
people only follow evil out of
ignorance.
It does, and it means we have to
accept that Saints can be
terrifying in their certainty,
that sinners sometimes are the
ones who feed hungry children,
that heroes sometimes commit
massacres to achieve a strategic
goal.
Freedom fighters plant bombs.
Terrorists distribute bread to
win loyalty, the source says.
The robes of a St. and the code
of a tyrant are often cut from
the same cloth.
It's only victory in the passage
of time that lets us neatly
label which was which and the
state the official layer.
One has a massive vested
interest in making sure those
labels are clear and absolute.
It needs to insist that its own
legitimacy is intrinsic,
God-given, and that anyone who
opposes it is inherently unjust.
But if we follow the sources
advice and just step back for a
second, if we look at the state
not morally, but purely
structurally, purely by its
architecture and function.
You arrive at the most stunning
conclusion in the entire
analysis.
That the state itself
structurally resembles the most
efficient cartel ever built.
Now hold on.
I have to push back on that.
That sounds like pure cynicism.
I mean, a democratic state
provides public schools, it
builds roads, it has courts and
accountability.
A cartel just murders its rivals
and sells drugs.
Surely there's a fundamental
difference.
And the sources would agree
there's a difference in stated
mission, in ideology, and
hopefully in outcome.
But they insist that if you look
only at the raw mechanisms of
power and control, the parallels
are undeniable and staggering.
OK, so let's break down those
parallel functions.
What are the mechanisms?
1st A monopoly on violence.
Both the state and a
sophisticated cartel claim the
exclusive right to use force
within their territory to
enforce their will.
Any other use of force is, by
their definition, illegal.
OK.
That's fair.
Second, mandatory revenue
collection.
The state calls it taxation.
It takes a cut of every
transaction in exchange for
providing services and
protection.
And the cartel calls it tribute
or protection money.
They take their cut in exchange
for providing their own version
of services and protection.
And in both systems, if you
refuse to pay, men with guns
will eventually show up at your
door. 3rd, and this is critical,
both the state and the cartel
are the sole arbiters of what is
legal and what is criminal
within their sphere of
influence.
The state uses its authority to
give medals to its killers,
calling them soldiers or police
officers.
And it uses that same authority
to put other killers who used
force without its permission in
a cage for the rest of their
lives, calling them criminals.
So the argument, the really
radical argument, is that the
conflict between the state and
these parallel authorities isn't
a moral crusade, it's a business
dispute.
It's a competition for monopoly
control.
The state layer one doesn't
arrest a layer two shot caller
because he uses violence, it
arrests him because he uses
unauthorized violence.
It arrests him because he's
running his own unauthorized tax
system and because he commands a
loyalty from the local
population that hasn't been
approved to the proper channels.
It's a fight over who gets to be
the sole provider of governance.
And if the state actually
provides the security, the jobs
and the justice the people need,
its position as layer one is
secure.
If it doesn't, a layer 2 entity,
whether it's an ideological
militia or a profit driven
cartel, will step in, perform
those state functions, and in
doing so earn a very real, very
powerful operational legitimacy
on the ground.
It is absolutely critical that
we state here, just as the
source analysis does repeatedly,
that this structural
interpretation is not a plea for
moral relativism.
It's not an argument for
shrugging our shoulders and
saying all violence is the same.
No, absolutely not.
This is a cold, hard look at the
architecture of power.
It's not an endorsement of any
of the players because the human
cost of this constant layer
dance for power is it's immense.
It's immediate and it's brutal.
Children die in this dance.
Families are shattered.
Addiction hollows out entire
communities.
Drone strikes can erase a human
body so completely that a
family's grief has to imagine
the bones of their loved one.
Because there's nothing left to
bury.
The suffering is the constant,
but to understand that suffering
and maybe to one day have a
chance of lessening it, we have
to understand the mechanics that
keep producing it.
One man's savior is another
man's tyrant.
One soldiers precision strike is
another family's empty chair at
the kitchen table.
The outrage people feel is
always real.
The grief is always real.
But the categories we use,
terrorist, soldier, criminal,
freedom fighter, martyr, those
are always, always negotiated.
They're defined by whoever is
currently in control of the most
powerful layer 1 mechanism.
The semantics are always for
sale, and the price is often
paid in blood.
This structural view just forces
us to admit that the very labels
we cling to for moral comfort
are often just the authorized
tools of power.
The sources leave us with this
one final, incredibly haunting
observation.
It's one that ties the foreign
and the domestic, the war zone
and the city street all
together.
It's about a strange kind of
symmetry.
It says that a major cartel
funeral with all its ceremony
and a formal military memorial
for a soldier killed in action.
They share a strange, rhyming
grief.
In both ceremonies, you have a
community mourning someone who
they believe down to the very
core of their being, died doing
what was right, what was
necessary for their people, for
their tribe, for their family.
That absolute, unshakable
conviction in their own
righteousness.
Yeah, it exists on all sides.
Sides.
And that, maybe, is the most
disturbing part of this entire
structure.
Which brings us to the final
thought.
The source material leaves us
with the question we want to
leave with you.
Should the fact that both
groups, the official state
soldier and the member of the
parallel authority, are so
equally and fiercely convinced
of their own moral
righteousness, should that
unsettle us more than the simple
fact that they shoot at each
other?
It suggests that the deepest
problem might not be the
violence itself, but the
absolute, uncompromising
certainty on every side that
fuels it layer by.
Layer our discussion today well,
it centers on the source
materials, exploration of
political legitimacy, power
structures, and the raw,
functional truth that's kind of
hidden within that old cliche
One man's freedom fighter is
another man's terrorist.
We're really exploring the
unsettling idea that this is
less of a paradox and more of a
a structural blueprint of modern
conflict.
Right.
And the structure we are
examining, this simultaneous
existence of the state, what it
calls layer one and these
parallel authorities layer 2, it
really forces us to rethink how
political legitimacy is actually
established and maybe more
importantly, maintained.
Absolutely.
So the central question we have
to address is this does the
material structural analysis of
power fundamentally reduce
political legitimacy to a purely
transactional outcome, something
negotiated solely through force
and opportunity?
Or does the state's claim to a
monopoly on authorized violence
maintain some kind of crucial,
non negotiable functional
distinction?
And I'll be arguing that despite
the moral ambiguities and and
the often egregious hypocrisy of
state action, the successful
enforcement of authorized verse
unauthorized violence, that
remains the defining functional
mechanism of governance.
And I think this mechanism
creates a difference that you
can't entirely reduce to just
semantics or transactional
outcomes.
And I'm going to argue the other
side that the structural and
functional overlaps revealed by
this 3 layers of power model,
they render those moral and
legal categories inherently
ambiguous.
I think in this environment,
legitimacy is fundamentally
negotiated, it's transactional
and at the end of the day it's
defined by the victor who gets
to write the history.
OK, let's unpack the
architecture then.
My position really begins with
this idea that the structural
equivalence between layer one
and layer 2 is well, it's an
operational truth.
I mean, when you look at the
modern state at layer one, it
structurally resembles what the
material calls the most
efficient cartel ever built.
And that's not just a
provocative statement, it's a
functional description.
The state defines who is a
soldier and who is a criminal.
It claims and usually enforces a
physical monopoly on violence.
And crucially, it takes a cut of
every single transaction.
OK, I can acknowledge the state
acts like a cartel, but what
makes it efficient?
I mean cartels extort states
text.
Why is that distinction merely
semantic?
Because the state has developed
these incredibly advanced tools
of extraction and enforcement
that layer 2 can only dream of.
It's more efficient because it
can seize assets legally, it can
enforce collection globally
through international treaties,
it prints the very currency that
layer 2 transactions rely on,
and it can leverage the threat
of legal imprisonment for non
compliance.
So these layer 2 authorities,
gangs, militias, cartels, they
essentially replicate the
structure.
They step into the vacuum left
by the state and become the gods
of small things.
They provide protection,
adjudicate disputes, manage
welfare, pay rent or offer
loans.
These are all services that meet
a genuine demand for governance.
So governance is just utility
then, regardless of the uniform?
Precisely if the function of
providing security and structure
is fulfilled, whether it's by
forms and fees or threats and
extortion, the underlying
reality is the same.
Legitimacy becomes a
transactional commodity based on
provision.
The semantics you know who is
the hero and who is the villain
are, as the material says,
always for sale when violence is
the ultimate currency.
That's a compelling, I'll admit,
albeit bleak, structural
reading.
But the legal framework that
Layer one enforces, that is the
key distinction I want to focus
on.
We agree the analysis of modern
conflict is deeply
uncomfortable, but Layer 2
authorities are pursued and
eliminated by Layer one not
because they use force, but
because they use unauthorized
force and collect taxes without
permission.
But again, that just sounds like
the strongest man getting to
define the rule book after he's
already won the fistfight.
Well, it is the strongest force
defining the rule book, yes, but
that successful definition
creates a necessary functional
difference.
The material details the
anatomical reality of modern
conflict.
It describes forces like the
seals and the SASA, centralized
professional army killing a
distributed ecology of
grievance.
This is not a clash of equals.
The power the state holds is the
institutional ability to assign
value and consequence to
violence.
They can label a guided bomb
drop on a populated St.
Precision necessity.
Regrettable but justified.
I mean, this is a form of
institutional coercion that
layer 2 simply cannot replicate
on a national scale.
And I agree that layer 2 lacks
that institutional capacity, but
only because layer one is
actively denying it to them,
usually with overwhelming
kinetic force.
But the longevity of layer One's
power rests on its legal
infrastructure.
The system defines who gets
medals and who was incarcerated
for life.
And furthermore, if layer 2 does
succeed in challenging layer
one, let's say a cartel
achieving some quasi state
status, it almost always
requires the alignment of layer
3 and that layer three.
Whether it's an external
intervention like NATO, federal
agencies like the DEA, or a
regional proxy power, it's what
validates or invalidates the
legitimacy of the challengers.
In the absence of that, Layer 3
validation ensures Layer 2
remains A localized existential
threat to the state, but not a
functional long term
replacement.
OK, let's delve into the anatomy
of conflict, because I think
this is where the state's claim
distinction really reveals
itself as a negotiation.
The material is unflinching on
this.
In the Global War on Terror,
many of the opponents who were
killed were legally non
combatants.
They were civilians who chose to
fight.
They weren't uniformed or
conscripted.
They were civilians fighting
soldiers.
It is a devastating definition,
soldiers killing civilians who
act like soldiers.
It's more than devastating.
It's structurally revealing.
The state engages in what you
could call linguistic triage,
calling them insurgent,
extremist or narco terrorist.
This language is designed to
obscure the reality that under
international law, the victim
was legally a civilian.
The state uses these labels to
create a moral distance, a
justification really to avoid
witnessing its own reflection.
The state, the most efficient
cartel, simply defines its own
unavoidable violent acts as
necessary and its opponents
necessary violent acts is
illegal.
The distinction is defined by
the power of the labeler, not
the inherent morality or
function of the ACT itself.
I agree that language is the
state's most powerful tool for
self justification.
I absolutely do.
However, the operational reality
that is rooted in the state's
functional claim to authority is
different, and that matters
profoundly for the structure.
An army has a verifiable chain
of command.
It has rules of engagement, a
national mandate, the
distributed opposition.
It lacks that they are fighting
to create a parallel governance
and that struggle over who
controls the legal apparatus of
force itself.
The very structure that dictates
who wins medals is a functional
fight, not just a semantic 1.
But the legal apparatus only
matters if it can fill the
vacuum, and that is exactly
where layer 2 governance proves
its transactional legitimacy.
You just have to look at the
vacuum effect and destabilize.
Zones like Iraq or in neglected
areas within functioning states,
the material frames these
outcomes not as intrinsic moral
failures, but as predictable
byproducts of neglected demand
and concentrated opportunity
when layer one collapses or
neglects its fundamental.
Responsibilities Layer 2 steps
in.
I acknowledge that the market
abhors a vacuum, and layer 2
fills it with astonishing speed.
Exactly.
Take the example of cartels or
local militias.
They become the primary
employers, the informal Social
Security, and the venture
capital source for entire
populations that the legitimate
economy just ignores when layer
one refuses to adjudicate a land
dispute or when a family needs
quick money for a medical
emergency.
Layer 2 is the Supreme Court and
the bank.
Its ruling is immediate, it's
credible, and it's enforced by
credible threat.
This demonstrates that
legitimacy is strictly
transactional.
Layer 2 provides provision and
immediate security in exchange
for loyalty and an acceptance of
risk.
Utility is the currency of
governance.
That's a compelling analysis of
utility, but I have to question
the functional equivalence based
on the nature of that
transaction and its
consequences.
I agree.
The illegal economy often offers
the only ladder available, but
layer one, for all its faults,
funds its extraction.
It's taxation by creating a
system that theoretically
provides public goods.
Broadly, Layer 2 provides
structure with the brutality of
a business and it's funded
directly by extortion by human
trafficking and the wholesale
distribution of destructive
substances like fentanyl.
But all governance is
extractive, and the history of
layer one is rife with brutality
and destruction in the name of
development.
Layer one is funded by income
tax, by bonds, and historically
by colonial extraction.
Layer 2 is funded by illicit
extraction.
Both are mandatory contributions
enforced by violence or the
threat of it.
The functional difference is 1
of scale and legality, not
foundational morality.
Well, I think the functional
distinction lies in the negative
externalities.
Layer 2's governance, rooted as
it is in illicit means, it
destabilizes the very community
it claims to protect through
addiction and perpetual
violence.
Furthermore, the material makes
it clear that Layer one
agencies, the DEA, the FBI, the
military, they have the ability
to cross Layer 2 boundaries and
dismantle those structures.
Layer 2 cannot raid the DEA.
That structural asymmetry means
layer one always retains the
ultimate functional legal power
to authorize the force used to
collect those extractions and
enforce its borders.
Your reliance on layer one's
ultimate course of capacity,
though, it forces us back to the
heart of this moral ambiguity.
If we accept the structural
equivalence of extraction, then
we have to accept the complexity
of historical judgment.
The source material presses this
point.
Saints are sometimes terrifying
sinners, sometimes feed
children.
History is indeed profoundly
untidy.
We can cite the example of the
regime that gassed millions but
also restored employment and
national pride to a shattered
nation.
The intent is to show that
fixed, clean moral categories,
they fail under rigorous
historical scrutiny.
Legitimacy, therefore, is
fundamentally contingent.
It's assigned after the fact by
the victorious storyteller.
If the insurgents win, they get
statues and are declared freedom
fighters.
If they lose, they are declared
terrorists and executed.
That is the definition of
transactional legitimacy.
The outcome dictates the
morality, not the other way
around.
I'm not convinced by that line
of reasoning, because it ignores
the constraints the material
itself provides.
While fixed categories certainly
fail, the analysis explicitly
includes a disclaimer.
None of this is a plea for moral
relativism or for shrugging
indifference.
The outrage, the grief, the
palpable suffering, shattered
families, the drone strikes that
literally erase bodies, The
widespread addiction.
These remain concrete realities,
regardless of what label we
apply to the perpetrator.
The outrage is absolutely real,
but the system designed to judge
that outrage is biased from the
start.
Yes, it is biased.
But the fact that both sides,
the cartel figure and the
military soldier, they both
mourn someone who died believing
they were doing the right thing,
that should unsettle us.
But it shouldn't convince us
that the fundamental
institutional power to authorize
violence is irrelevant.
The state's ability to create
the system that judges those
acts is the ultimate functional
distinction.
Our focus should be on the
impact of these negotiated
categories on the people who
experience the real
consequences.
The system dictates who can
legally drop the bomb and walk
away with a medal, and who uses
force and receives life in a
maximum security cell.
That power defines the
consequences.
That power, however, is rooted
solely in capacity and
historical success, not in any
inherent moral superiority.
And that is the structuralist
argument.
Capacity defines the definition.
But the architecture of Layer
one allows for a stability, a
scale, and a longevity that
Layer 2, by its unauthorized
nature and its perpetual
criminal status, simply cannot
sustain without constant
external challenge.
The state's claim to
authorization is not just a
narrative, it's the structural
element that ensures its
durability.
This has been a rigorous and I
think a very necessary
dissection of the source
materials challenging
architecture.
My position remains that the
functional analysis of the three
layers and the structural
equivalence between the state
and parallel authorities.
It reveals that legitimacy is
fundamentally negotiated,
transactional, and ultimately
defined by the victor who
successfully enforces their
narrative.
The claim to authorize violence
is the state's most powerful
tool of negotiation, but it is
not an intrinsic, non negotiable
truth.
And I maintain that while states
often act precisely like the
most efficient cartel, the power
to define that authorization, to
enforce it institutionally, and
to scale it nationally remains
the central functional
difference.
Layer 1 controls the mechanism
of lasting legal power, the
power to give medals or maximum
security, and that institutional
difference keeps layer two in
the status of a perpetual
challenger, never a true peer.
The distinction between
authorized and unauthorized
force remains the most defining
mechanism of modern governance.
I think the enduring value of
this analysis, as the source
material makes clear, is that it
forces this uncomfortable
realization that the outrage
over violence is always real and
palpable.
Even as the.
Categories we use to define that
violence, whether terrorist,
freedom fighter or precision
strike, are always subject to
negotiation and change based on
power dynamics Indeed.
This discussion confirms the
necessity of rigorously
challenging the moral
certainties that language
imposes on conflict, so thank
you.
We're looking at today one man's
freedom fighter, another man's
terrorist.
Really gets into how that cliche
is an operational truth, using a
three layer model of power to
show how legitimacy gets
negotiated.
It's a sharp piece.
It cuts right to the bone of
modern conflict and control.
You know why?
Those definitions shift
depending on who's holding the
gun.
Our job today is to help sharpen
that structure and make the
emotional punch land even
harder.
Absolutely.
And looking at the model itself,
I think there's a huge
opportunity right away.
So the material establishes this
really compelling framework, the
three layers of power, right?
The official state, the parallel
authority, and the foreign or
federal power.
But the narrative would be so
much stronger with a deeper look
at the functional symbiosis or
even the strategic tolerance
between layer one and layer
there too.
That's the perfect place to
start.
That's the Nexus we need to
explore.
Yeah.
It is right now the framework
sort of emphasizes the idea that
layer 2, the parallel authority,
it only steps in where layer one
fails.
Right.
It's that nature aboors a vacuum
model.
The state falls apart, so the
cartel or the militia steps in
to manage food routes or jobs or
whatever it is.
And that model, it's, it's a
little too neat.
It is.
The weakness is that it frames
the relationship purely as this
failure vacuum scenario, and
that just misses the
intentionality.
You know, it overlooks the
political engineering that
happens when Layer 1 isn't just
helpless or collapsed, but is
strategically managing its own
limited resources.
Exactly.
So we need to introduce this
element of of deliberate
negotiation or calculated
alliances, even between the
official state and the parallel
authority.
Yes, we need to challenge that
simple failure model and show
how layer 2 authorities
sometimes perform layer one
functions because the state
chooses to let them.
It's outsourcing.
Because some of those functions
are politically toxic.
I mean the official state layer
one, it might not want its
fingerrints on controlling, say,
certain supply chains or
enforcing a certain kind of
local brutality, but it
absolutely needs the stability
that those layer two groups
provide.
O let's get concrete on that.
We need to detail some instances
where layer one officials might
tolerate specific smuggling
bosses or or local shot callers
from layer 2, right?
As long as those figures, you
know, guarantee a reduction in
lower level St. violence, or
they keep specific supply chains
open, that totally changes layer
one from a victim into a a
calculated manager of delegated
illegal power.
And then from the other side,
the parallel authority, whether
it's a gang or a cartel, is
sophisticated enough to play its
part.
They do this by mimicking the
very bureaucracy they're
supposedly fighting against.
Oh, yeah.
We should expand on how they use
these pseudo legal structures
like enforce contracts,
protection schemes, internal
dispute resolution, all things
that, you know, actively
replicate the bureaucratic
brutality of the state.
It shows they're not just
filling a void with chaos,
they're actually replicating
systems of governance, complete
with penalties and enforce
loyalty.
It's why they stick around.
And this ties so perfectly into
the part about sanctuary cities.
It's already a great example of
layer one resisting Layer 3.
The feds, sure, but we can link
it explicitly to this idea of
strategic tolerance.
That declaration isn't just
about ethics.
It's also about Layer one
officials wanting to better
control or leverage their
existing Layer 2 structures.
The piece already has has that
brilliant line.
Better our devils than your
angels.
Exactly.
We just need to make sure the
analysis fully supports that
strategic calculus show that the
state is preserving its right to
manage its own parallel
authority, not just, you know,
protecting some abstract idea of
autonomy.
It makes the whole dynamic so
much more unsettling and
sophisticated.
It stops being a simple
hierarchy and becomes this
really complex negotiated web of
shared power.
And Speaking of unsettling that,
that brings us to the weight of
all these definitions.
So look, the closing segment
powerfully articulates this
moral discomfort.
You know that Saints can be
terrifying, sinners can feed
children.
Categories are always
negotiated.
But integrating this thematic
tension earlier will just raise
the narrative stakes through the
entire piece.
The moral core of this thing is
undeniable, and that conclusion,
it hits so hard.
The problem is really one of
pacing all the most visceral
stuff.
The drone strikes, erasing
bodies, the empty chairs at the
table from addiction.
That line about the rhyming
grief of a cartel funeral and a
military memorial.
It's almost all saved for the
last two paragraphs.
And the weakness there is that
it risks making the moral
ambiguity feel like a like a
philosophical punchline, a deep
thought at the end.
Yeah, a conclusion.
Right.
Instead of the core ethical
challenge that should be driving
the political anatomy from the
very beginning, it's like we
dissect the machine first, and
only then do we look at the
people that shoot up.
We need to merge those things.
We need to flip that
relationship entirely.
The trauma has to inform the
dissection.
So the suggestion is introduce
the human stakes right after you
establish that initial
operational truth.
Those unsettling outcomes, the
shattered families, the missing
bones, the empty kitchen chairs,
They should be used to ground
abstract concepts like
linguistic triage.
Because the pain of that triage
is never abstract, right?
It's a specific missing face at
a dinner table.
Always.
So when the peace defines the
anatomy of modern conflict, that
bit about soldiers killing
civilians who are acting like
soldiers, we should immediately
follow it up.
Link the state's language.
You know, precision, necessity,
regrettable but justified.
Link that directly to the
immediate, visceral feeling of
grief that makes the cost of the
word itself immediate.
And that gives the whole
critique an ethical pulse from
start to finish.
We can weave in that idea that
the outrage is always real much
earlier, maybe when it describes
how layer 2 entities become
these gods of small things,
providing insurance or capital,
but with much faster penalties.
That's a critical connection.
You're linking the transactional
benefits of layer 2 directly to
the moral ambiguity of why it
even exists.
You're showing the reader that
the system is built on these
heartbreaking sacrifices
happening in real time, not just
in the epilogue.
And that observation that a
cartel funeral and a military
memorial share a strange,
rhyming grief instead of saving
it for the end, It would be a
perfect midpoint transition.
Oh, that's good.
Use it to bridge the global
conflict analysis to the
domestic application.
It signals to the reader that
this uncomfortable moral parody
isn't just a theory.
It's structural.
It's immediate.
That one small structural change
would make the piece so much
more engaging.
Because the reader is constantly
confronted with the human weight
of these definitions, the
analysis never gets a chance to
become sterile before you hit
them with that emotional payoff.
Which I think leads us very
naturally to our third major
focus, which is really about
enhancing the domestic
application of this model O.
The piece makes this really
creative leap, applying the
three layer model to places like
Baltimore and Chicago, but the
structural parallels between
layer 3 abroad, the occupiers,
and layer three at home like the
DEA or FBI, they could be made
way more explicit and
actionable.
Yeah, the domestic application
is strong when it's defining
layer 2.
It really nails how gangs
provide services, the jobs,
fraternity insurance.
It.
Does.
But the weakness is that it
doesn't fully develop how the
operational philosophy of the
federal layer 3 structurally
mirrors the destabilizing
actions of the foreign layer
three.
It asserts the comparison
between the war on drugs and the
War on Terror, but the mechanism
of destabilization feels a
little underdeveloped on the
domestic side.
Right.
The foreign intervention is
shown to disrupt the power
balance, which frees up layer 2
to reconfigure their ambitions
create vacuums.
All that opportunism, yeah.
We need to see that same
mechanical destabilizing impact
applied explicitly to federal
intervention here at home.
It's not just about policing,
it's about structural
disruption.
Exactly.
So the suggestion here is to
strengthen that domestic
analogy, detail the specific
ways federal intervention
operates like a foreign power.
You know, enforcing mandates
from somewhere far away,
destabilizing the local power
balance and inadvertently
empowering rival Layer 2
factions, just like the
coalition did in Iraq.
You know, remove one dictator,
you get 10 warlords.
So we need to show the
operational similarities, like
what are the parallels between
counterterrorism tactics used
globally and the deployment of
tactical gear and special units
by the DEA or FBI in American
cities?
Yes.
We should focus on how those
actions are really targeting
unauthorized force and
unapproved loyalty, maybe even
more than they're targeting a
reduction in actual harm.
It's about maintaining the
state's monopoly on violence,
even if it makes things more
violent locally in the short
term.
And you have to elaborate on the
direct consequences.
What happens when the Federal
Layers intervention creates a
localized vacuum by taking out a
layer 2 liter?
It creates chaos.
It leads to intense internal
conflict among, as the tech
says, kids with no prospects
strapping ambition to
adrenaline.
I mean, that's a perfect echo of
what happens after a region
change abroad.
Show the reader that the method
of intervention is what causes
the chaos, regardless of the
stated goal.
And then finally, we should lean
into the text.
Powerful assertion that the
state is like the most efficient
cartel ever built.
Give specific examples of how
the federal layer 3 applies its
monopoly on violence and its
ability to tax without
permission at home.
Things like civil forfeiture,
prod federal mandates, the
ability to operate totally
outside of local politics.
If that analogy holds, then the
federal government has to be
shown acting like a supremely
powerful, legally sanctioned
Layer 2, not just an outside
police force.
Connecting those dots
structurally makes the
comparison truly operational.
It shows that whether it's the
foreign layer 3IN Magdad or the
federal layer 3 in Baltimore,
the mechanism for control and
disruption follows the same
violent pattern.
You replace one unapproved power
structure with approved, but
often just as volatile
competition.
This is an incredibly robust
piece of writing.
I mean, it tackles one of the
most frustrating moral and
political riddles of our time.
And the three main areas for
refinement are, I think, clear
and they're all interconnected.
So just to recap the actionable
steps here, first explicitly
analyze the strategic tolerance
and political engineering
between the official state layer
one and the parallel authority
layer 2.
Move beyond that simple failure
vacuum model and really show the
intentionality behind the
outsourcing of power. 2nd
Integrate that powerful moral
ambiguity, that devastating
human cost much earlier in the
narrative.
Let the visceral sticks, the
missing bodies, the rhyming
grief.
Let that drive the structural
analysis instead of just serving
as the philosophical conclusion.
And 3rd, strengthen the domestic
analogy.
Detail the structural
similarities between foreign and
federal intervention Layer 3 by
focusing on how federal action
functionally destabilizes local
power balances through that
targeted external enforcement.
These are really specific,
actionable suggestions.
They're all aimed at maximizing
the impact and the internal
logic of an already compelling
thesis.
If you implement these, the
critique will shift from being a
powerful observation to an
unforgettable argument.
We'd really encourage you to
send your revised work.
Back in, it gets trotted out
anytime a conversation about
conflict gets a little too
uncomfortable.
One man's freedom fighter is
another man's terrorist.
Exactly.
And most of the time people say
with this little shrug, you
know, like it's just some
cynical Hallmark card wisdom we
can look at and then put away.
But the sources we're diving
into today, they are really
insistent on this point.
They argue that this isn't just
a paradox, it's it's a blunt
operational truth about how the
world actually functions.
And that's our mission for this
deep dive.
We're going to take that saying
completely seriously, because
when you do, you start to see
the, well, the real architecture
of how power and violence are
negotiated.
And we should be upfront here.
It's a deeply uncomfortable
thing to look at.
It is because it shows you that
legitimacy isn't some fixed
moral thing handed down from on
high.
Not at all.
Legitimacy is it's negotiated
minute by minute.
It's hammered out by who has the
biggest gun, who controls the
food, who can offer revenge or
opportunity, and maybe most
importantly, by the stories
people tell themselves about why
they deserve to win.
OK, let's unpack all of that.
And I think we have to jump
straight into the most, let's
call it radioactive example in
our sources.
The global War on Terror.
Yeah, because it immediately
throws this fundamental
asymmetry of modern conflict
into sharp relief.
And we have to start with the
legal definitions.
Think about all the people
America targeted and killed over
the last two decades.
Afghanistan.
Iraq.
Somalia.
All over.
Right.
Every single person on the
receiving end of a drone strike
or a raid was, by a strict legal
definition, a civilian.
That's a strong claim.
I mean, people here insurgent,
militant.
So what do you mean by civilian?
It means they weren't
conscripted soldiers, they
weren't wearing a state issued
uniform or fighting under a
recognized national flag.
They were, you know, farmers,
shopkeepers, unemployed kids who
chose to join a 'cause they
chose to pick up a gun.
OK, so now contrast that with
the other side, the force sent
to hunt them.
Well, these weren't farmers who
decided to fight.
These are the most professional,
most highly specialized soldiers
that modernity has ever created.
You're talking about tier one
special forces.
Exactly.
JSOC's teams, Navy Seals, the
British way.
These are highly trained, state
funded professionals paid by
sovereign states to neutralize
people those same states have
labeled as threats.
So the whole picture of modern
war isn't to armies in clean
lines, it's something else.
It's what the sources call an
army and a distributed ecology
of grievance.
Wow.
It's professional soldiers
killing civilians who are acting
like soldiers.
And this is where the asymmetry
becomes total, because the state
controls the language, and
language is the ultimate tool
for triage.
Triage is the perfect word.
It's how we decide who gets
moral consideration, right?
The sources really dig into how
we use these words.
Sort of avoid looking in the
mirror.
Absolutely.
The label we apply is all about
whose interests are being
served.
So if a civilian, a 20 year old
kid, detonates a bomb in a
market, we all immediately agree
that's terrorism?
It's the highest moral
condemnation possible.
Right, but what if that same
kid, or maybe his brother, fires
a rifle out of patrol that, say,
just bulldozed his uncle's farm?
The label shifts.
Now he's an insurgent, a
fighter, maybe still a terrorist
depending on the headline.
See.
But notice what happens when the
force is reversed, when the
state uses its most advanced
weapon to drop a guided bomb on
a house to kill one single
person who joined the wrong
banner.
We call that a precision strike,
a necessity.
Regrettable but justified.
It's a linguistic sleight of
hand, and the moral weight just
depends on who's holding the
dictionary.
And to understand why that
reflection keeps popping up, we
have to look at the structure
underneath it all.
This is where the sources bring
in this framework.
The three layers of power.
They argue that in any contested
area, these three layers are
operating at the same time.
OK, so let's make this concrete.
The sources used post invasion
Iraq as the main example.
What were the layers there?
OK, so layer one is the official
state, the government on paper?
Ministries, police, the flag,
the guys giving press
conferences.
Exactly.
They have the official seal of
approval, but in a place like
Iraq after 2003, they often had
very little actual power on the
ground.
So who did that?
Must be layer 2.
Layer 2, The parallel authority.
This is where the real power is.
These are the men whose phone
calls mattered more than any
official government decree.
The sheiks, The clerics.
The tribal leaders, the
smuggling bosses, the families
who controlled the water and
food routes, they were the ones
who actually ran things
day-to-day.
And the third layer.
Layer 3 is the foreign power, in
this case the coalition, the
occupiers.
They're the ones with the
fighter jets and the big
military bases.
They have the ultimate
firepower.
And all three are there at once,
all competing, sometimes
colliding.
Constantly, and this is where
the sources get really sharp.
Foreign intervention doesn't
just replace layers 1 and 2.
It destabilizes them.
It creates a vacuum.
When the Coalition came in, they
chopped the head off of layer
one and sort of pushed layer 3
down.
But in doing so they knocked the
legs out from under layer 2.
They broke the old equilibrium.
And power vacuums they'd always
get.
Filled and not by the most noble
people.
It's predictable.
You get the men who just lost
power trying to claw it back.
You get the guys who were almost
in power, the mid level
operators making a grab for it.
And then you get the people who
never even dreamed of having
power.
The kids, the young men taking
absolutely insane risks and the
sources are so clear on this.
It's all the same pool of
people.
Some become villains, some
become the new US backed mayors
and some become martyrs.
That framework, the three
layers, the vacuum, once you see
it, you can't Unsee it.
And it's not just over there.
That's the unsettling part.
The sources draw this Direct
Line, saying America talks about
its own inner cities the way it
talks about foreign conflict
zones.
As moral failures, failures of
character or culture.
Instead of seeing them as
predictable results of a layered
power structure where the
official state has failed.
OK, so let's apply the model.
Take a city like Baltimore or
Chicago.
Layer One.
That's easy.
The mayor, City Council, the
police commissioner, the
official government.
And layer 2, the parallel
authority on the streets.
This is the crucial one.
It's the cruise, the gangs, the
shop callers.
They're the ones who really
decide who gets a job, who's
protected and who gets hurt for
crossing a line.
They run the Gray economy.
They provide the immediate
security.
And layer 3, the foreign power
in this analogy, that would be
the federal government.
Precisely.
The DEA, The FBI, Homeland
Security.
They roll in with their tactical
gear to enforce federal laws,
often completely ignoring the
delicate, violent balance of
Layer 2.
Which gives a whole new meaning
to something like a sanctuary
city debate.
The public rhetoric is all about
compassion.
But structurally, it's a fight
over who gets to police Layer 2.
The local government is
essentially telling the federal
government layer three, these
are our problems.
We understand them better than
you do.
The unspoken part is better our
devils than your angels.
Because if you just come in and
wipe out layer 2 without
replacing it with a trusted
functional layer one, you don't
get peace, you get another
vacuum.
And that's where, as the sources
put it, kids with no prospects
strap ambition to adrenaline.
Suddenly, the war on drugs
starts to look operationally
identical to the War on Terror.
They're fighting the same thing,
non state actors who build a
parallel government where the
official one has failed to feed,
protect or respect people.
A cartel, like a militia,
provides structure.
It comes with obedience and
risk, but it's structure.
And that's where the cartel
becomes this paradoxical
benefactor.
I mean, to the US government,
it's a massive threat.
Of course.
But if you're a citizen living
inside that system, a cartel can
be a job when there are no jobs.
It can be a fraternity when you
have no family.
It can be your insurance, your
protection.
The gods of small things, as the
source material calls them.
Yes, they're the ones handling
rent, covering hospital bills,
paying bail.
They are performing the
functions of the state.
They just fund it with cocaine
and extortion.
And that ambiguity is what makes
us so uncomfortable.
We want our villains to be
villains, full stop.
We want clean lines, but the
sources just demolish that idea.
The summary is so powerful.
One man's illegal militia is
another's Volunteer Fire
Department, code enforcement and
welfare office all wrapped into
one.
And history is full of his
complication.
We want to believe evil
announces itself clearly.
But it rarely does.
The sources use that incredibly
tough example of the German
regime in the 30s, the same
regime that built gas chambers
also simultaneously restored
employment and a sense of
national pride to a completely
broken country.
Which doesn't redeem the horror
for a second.
Not at all.
But it complicates everything.
It forces you to see that
tyranny can show up promising
competence, that sinners
sometimes feed children, that
the coat of the tyrant and the
robe of the Saint are often on
the same hook.
And that leads us all the way
back to the state itself, Layer
one, if you look at it from far
enough away.
It starts to look structurally
like the most successful cartel
ever built.
It claims a monopoly on violence
in the territory.
And it takes a cut of every
single transaction.
We call it taxes.
It uses force to maintain its
existence.
So the state arrests these
parallel leaders not because
they use force.
The state uses force all the
time.
It arrests them because they use
unauthorized force, they command
loyalty, and they tax without
permission.
It's a fight over who owns the
copyright on governance.
But even as we talk about this
geometry of power, we have to
remember the human cost.
This isn't just a thought
experiment.
No children die, families are
shattered.
And the sources point out this
this strange and awful symmetry
that a military memorial for a
soldier and a cartel funeral for
a sicario share a strange,
rhyming grief.
The loss is just as real.
So bringing it all home, right
One soldiers precision strike is
another family's empty chair at
the dinner table.
And the categories we use,
terrorist, freedom fighter,
patriot, criminal, they're
always up for negotiation.
The semantics are for sale and
blood is the currency.
The most unsettling truth from
all this for me isn't just that
these groups are shooting at
each other.
No, it's something deeper.
It's the fact that both groups,
the state sanctioned soldier and
the leader of the parallel
authority, are absolutely, 100%
convinced of their own
righteousness.
They both truly believe they are
doing right by their people.
That shared, unwavering
conviction, that's the engine
driving this whole architecture
of power.
And maybe the real question for
you to think about is what that
means for the next conflict or
the next power vacuum that's
already taking shape, maybe even
in your own community, on
defining power and legitimacy in
modern conflict.
You know that old saying, one
man's freedom fighter is another
man's terrorist?
Well, this is all about what
that actually means on the
ground.
It shows that legitimacy isn't
some fixed moral thing.
It's negotiated with force and
by providing what people need.
So let's break down the three
big takeaways.
OK, first up, modern war isn't
really two armies clashing.
It's professional soldiers
fighting armed civilians.
The people haunted in the War on
Terror, for example, were
legally civilians who had joined
non state groups.
And the language is telling,
right?
If a civilian fighter sets off a
bomb, it's terrorism.
But if the state drops a guided
bomb on that same person, that's
called a precision strike.
Second, governance often works
on three different levels all at
once.
And this happens everywhere from
conflict zones to American
cities.
You've got layer one, the
official state, you know, police
and bureaucrats.
Then there's layer 2, the
parallel authority.
Think gangs or sheiks, the
people whose phone calls
actually get things done.
And finally layer 3 is that
outside power, like an occupying
army or the DEA.
And finally these non state
actors fill the vacuum when the
official state fails.
I mean, if the legal economy
offers you nothing but a cartel,
gives you a job or pays your
hospital bill, they become
essential.
They provide real structure.
And that's why one person's
narco terrorist is another's
neighborhood security.
The labels of villain and hero
just depend on who actually
delivers what you need.
The outrage is always real, but
the semantics of who is a
patriot and who is a criminal.
A really powerful way of looking
at conflict and control.
You know how it actually works
on the ground?
The source material for this
explainer calls it the Three
Layers of Power.
Let's get into it.
You've heard this line a million
times, right?
People love to drop it into a
conversation.
It makes them sound smart, like
they're seeing both sides of a
really complex issue.
But let's be honest, most of the
time it's just a way to shut
down the conversation without
anyone having to question what
they already believe.
But what if we stop treating it
like some cynical conversation
ending cliche?
What if we actually took it
literally?
The argument here is that if you
do that, the whole hidden
structure of power just clicks
into place.
It shows you that legitimacy
isn't some moral absolute, It's
something that's constantly
being fought over, negotiated,
often with force.
So yeah, let's use this cliche
not as a dead end, but as a key.
A key that might just unlock the
very architecture of power
itself.
OK, think about the War on
Terror.
The people America was fighting
were technically speaking,
civilians, right?
They didn't wear state
sanctioned uniforms that didn't
belong to a national army.
They got called all sorts of
things.
Insurgents, extremists, narco
terrorists.
And who was hunting them?
The most professional, best
equipped state funded soldiers
in the world.
This whole thing shows you a
really weird asymmetry.
Terrorism gets defined as
civilians killing other
civilians, But counterterrorism?
Well, that ends up looking a lot
like professional soldiers
killing civilians who are
fighting back like soldiers.
And the words, the words we use
to.
Describe all this are absolutely
crucial.
They aren't just descriptions,
they're weapons.
I mean, just look at the
contrast when they commit an act
of violence.
It's terrorism, it's insurgency,
extremism.
But when we do something that is
the exact same outcome, well,
that's a precision strike.
That was a necessity.
It was justified.
The result might be identical,
but the label we stick on it
does a complete 180 depending on
who's responsible.
The source material just nails
it with this line.
Language acts like a filter.
It sorts all the violence into
these neat little boxes, good
violence, bad violence, so that
we don't have to look in the
mirror and see the uncomfortable
reflection of our own action.
So all of this brings us to the
main event, the central idea of
this explainer.
Drawing on observations from
places like Iraq, we can start
to see power working on three
different layers all at the same
time.
First, you've got layer one.
This is the official state.
The government ministries, The
national police.
The.
Flag you see on buildings, it's
the power you see on TV.
But underneath that there's
layer 2, the parallel authority.
These are the real local power
brokers, the sheiks, the gang
leaders, the smugglers, the guys
whose phone call can get things
done faster than any official
decree.
And then you have layer 3, the
external power, the occupiers,
the coalition forces, maybe even
peacekeepers.
And the crucial thing to get
here is that these layers don't
just sit on top of each other.
They're all there at once,
constantly crashing into each
other, fighting for control.
And this is exactly where things
get so explosive when an
external power.
That's Layer 3 comes in and
kicks the legs out from under
the official state.
Layer one.
It doesn't create stability, it
creates a vacuum, a power
vacuum, and that empty space.
It's the perfect opportunity for
those parallel authorities in
Layer 2 to rise up and make a
grab for real power.
Now you might be thinking, OK,
this makes sense for a war zone
overseas, but what if that same
structure, that same geometry of
power is happening right here at
home?
Let's take this idea from
Baghdad and see what it looks
like in a city like Chicago.
See, the argument is that
America talks about its own
inner cities with the exact same
language it uses for foreign
conflict zones, as if they're
these far off alien places
instead of a totally predictable
outcome of how power is
structured.
And when you actually map it
out, the parallel is, well, it's
pretty startling.
In a major American city, Layer
one is the mayor's office and
the city police force.
Layer 3 is the federal
government, the DEA, the FBI,
Homeland Security, And Layer 2,
while that's the parallel
authority of the street gangs,
the crews, the shock callers who
actually control what happens on
a given block.
It's the same three layer game,
just with different players.
So why do these layer two
groups, whether it's militias or
cartels or street gangs, why do
they even exist?
It's pretty simple, really.
They provide governance where
the official state can't or
won't.
They offer jobs, a sense of
structure protection.
They become, as the source puts
it, gods of small things.
They're the ones you go to for
help with rent or a hospital
bill, or to get revenge.
They act like a government, but
they operate with the raw
brutality of a business.
And this is where the whole
model gets really uncomfortable
because if you follow it to its
logical conclusion, it messes
with our deep seated need to
have clear heroes and villains.
Just think about it.
The official state claims the
exclusive right to use violence,
it collects taxes, and it gets
to define who is and who isn't a
criminal.
Now look at a cartel or any
other powerful layer two group.
It uses violence, it collects
taxes through extortion, and it
definitely defines its own
enemies.
The functions are shockingly
similar.
The only real difference is 1
has official permission and the
other doesn't.
This leads to a really profound
and kind of heartbreaking human
truth.
Both sides mourn their dead with
the exact same sense of
conviction.
Both sides truly believe they
were fighting for their own
people, for what was right.
The grief rhymes because the
belief behind it rhymes too.
And that's what this all boils
down to, really.
All our abstract labels,
terrorist, soldier, extremist,
patriot, they all just dissolve
into a very real, very human
price.
A precision strike sounds clean
and surgical from thousands of
feet up, but on the ground it's
just a suddenly, violently empty
chair at a family's dinner
table.
Which leaves us with a final,
and pretty unsettling question.
If every single side is
absolutely convinced of its own
righteousness, then who actually
gets to draw the line between
the hero and the villain?
And what does it mean if that
line isn't drawn by morality at
all, but just by who has the
most?
Power.
You know, there's that saying,
the one that gets pulled out in
basically any conversation about
conflict.
Oh, I know exactly which one you
mean.
We've all used it.
One man's freedom fighter is
another man's terrorist.
Exactly.
And it's it's sort of the
perfect conversation under,
isn't it?
It's this neat little
philosophical shrug.
It lets us acknowledge that
things are complicated and then,
you know, just move on without
getting our hands dirty.
Right.
It's a weighted gesture and
moral ambiguity.
But the the stack of sources
we've been digging into for this
deep dive, they make a really
provocative argument.
They say it's not just some
clever paradox.
No, not at all.
They call it a blunt operational
truth.
A blunt operational truth.
And what they mean by that is
that the phrase doesn't just
describe a feeling or a point of
view.
It actually reveals the literal
visible architecture of how
power works, how it's won, how
it's lost, and how it's
maintained.
And I think that's really our
mission for you today.
We're going to try and unpack
that architecture.
We're stepping away from the
comfortable moral certainties
and looking at material that
suggests legitimacy isn't some
fixed heavenly category.
Yeah, negotiated.
It's totally negotiated, it's a
high stakes negotiation and the
currency isn't abstract
morality, it's it's practical
things, it's hunger, it's
humiliation, it's the need for
vengeance, and maybe most
importantly, it's just pure, raw
opportunity.
So the core idea right from the
jump is that if you stop looking
at legitimacy as this absolute
good versus evil thing and start
seeing it as a, well, a
practical contest for loyalty
and resources.
Then the whole geometry of power
just snaps into focus.
You can see it clearly.
And the sources warn us, seeing
that geometry, really seeing it
can be, and I'm quoting here,
deeply uncomfortable.
It is because it's messy.
It forces you to look at
governance itself as something
transactional.
The sources are pretty clear.
When a formal government fails
to provide for its people,
whether that's through
corruption or just incompetence,
a vacuum is created.
And something always fills a
vacuum.
Always.
And the things that fill it,
they almost always involve 2 key
ingredients, cash and guns.
So our goal today is to analyze
how that vacuum gets filled and,
crucially, how language is used
to either, you know, sanitize or
demonize whoever steps in to
fill it.
OK, so let's get into that.
Let's unpack this architectural
analysis using the example the
material offers up as the
simplest but also the most
volatile.
The most radioactive one?
Yeah.
The global War on Terror, it
really does bring all these
definitions into sharp relief.
It's the perfect starting point
because when you look at
conflicts like Iraq or
Afghanistan through this
particular lens, all of our
standard comfortable definitions
like combatant and civilian,
they just immediately start to
destabilize.
They really do.
I mean, the analysis we reviewed
makes this one observation that
is so stark you really have to
just stop and sit with it for a
second.
Says that by the strict legal
definitions of warfare, you know
the Geneva Conventions, rules
about state uniforms, ranks,
formal armies.
The rules of the game, so to
speak.
Exactly.
By those rules, every single
person America and its allies
killed in that war was
technically a civilian.
And that's a statement that just
sounds wrong on 1st hearing,
doesn't it?
But it demands you look closer.
We're so conditioned to think of
war as state versus state to
armies in different colored
uniforms meeting on a field.
Right, but that's not what this
was.
You had individuals who for a
whole spectrum of reasons,
ideology, desperation, money,
revenge, chose to pick up a
weapon.
They chose to, yeah.
They weren't conscripted into
the Iraqi National Army.
They were, you know, farmers,
shopkeepers, engineers who
joined a faction.
They joined something else, and
you can see the intervening
powers struggling with what do
you even call them?
Are they insurgents, Extremists,
Foreign fighters?
Militia.
Narco terrorists.
The label kept shifting.
But their fundamental status
didn't.
They were non state actors.
They were operating completely
outside the traditional
framework of recognized nation
state armies.
And here's the other side of
that coin, the chilling
distinction the source material
makes the people sent to kill
them.
Yeah, they were the complete
opposite.
They weren't civilians at all.
They were the most professional,
state sanctioned, highly trained
killers that the modern world
has ever produced.
We're talking JOC teams, Navy
Seal's, Delta Force, Marine
Raiders, the British S, S and
SBS.
And you have to include the
drone crews, people sitting in a
container in Nevada operating
with the full legal backing and
protection of a superpower
state.
So you have these professional
state soldiers, paid and
protected by their governments,
sent to hunt and kill people who
are by definition, civilians.
Civilians who lack any of those
state protections, but whom the
state has conveniently relabeled
as enemy combatants to, you
know, make the whole thing
legally possible.
And that right there is the
anatomy of modern conflict.
When you strip it down to its
operational parts, it's not 2
armies fighting, it's one very
powerful state army facing what
the analysis calls a distributed
ecology of grievance, ideology,
desperation and opportunity.
That's such a great phrase, an
ecology of grievance.
It is because it's not a
monolith.
It's a multi headed,
decentralized, constantly
shifting reaction to a
catastrophic failure of local
governance.
Which brings us to the role of
language.
Because you can't fight in
ecology with traditional
military terms, so you have to
invent new ones.
Language itself becomes a tool,
a weapon even.
It becomes a tool of
categorization.
The sources call it language
triage.
Language triage I like.
That yeah, it's the idea that
violence is sorted and labeled
based on one simple metric.
Who is wielding it and whose
interests does it serve?
So it's not about the ACT
itself, it's about the actor.
Precisely.
And I think it's worth walking
through the examples they give
because it makes the mechanism
so clear.
If we can for just a moment step
back from the gut level moral
reaction and just look at the
raw action and the label that
are recognized, layer one
authority would apply to it.
OK, let's do it.
Scenario 1A Civilian walks into
a crowded market and detonates a
bomb.
The intent is to kill other
civilians for a political cause.
The label is a media.
It's universal.
That is terrorism.
No debate.
The ACT is civilian on civilian
violence.
OK.
Now same person, different
scenario.
He doesn't go to the market.
Instead, he takes a rifle and
fires at a foreign military
patrol that's rolling through
his neighborhood.
A patrol that, let's say, just
last week, bulldozed his
cousin's farm to clear a line of
sight.
Suddenly the language shifts.
The state aligned media, the
military press briefings, they
don't call it terrorism anymore.
Now it's insurgency, maybe
rebellion.
The ACT is still a civilian
attacking people with guns, but
the target has changed.
The target has changed, and the
motive is now framed as
grievance, not just pure
ideology.
It's seen as an attempt to fight
a state actor, not terrorize a
population.
The label changes the moral
weight of the ACT.
And it gets even messier, right?
Way messier.
OK, so picture a group of local
guys.
They set up an illegal
checkpoint on a key smuggling
Rd.
They've got guns and they're
forcing every trek that passes
to pay a tax.
So armed robbery, extortion.
Well, it depends.
If that checkpoint is, say,
Prime, primarily disrupting a
rival smuggling group that
happens to be an enemy of the
new Layer 1 government, then the
state might just look the other
way.
So they tolerate.
It they might even quietly
support it.
And in the official reports it
gets called militia activity.
It's framed as a sort of local
self policing initiative, a
tolerable parallel authority.
But if that same checkpoint
starts taxing, say, government
supply convoys or harassing
officials loyal to the Capitol?
The label flips overnight.
Instantly.
It's no longer militia activity.
Now it's extremist violence.
It's an organized criminal
enterprise.
The underlying action, illegal
taxation enforced by the barrel
of a gun, is identical, but its
relationship to the state's
interest determines its name.
And then there's a state's owned
violence, the final piece of the
triage.
Right when the state or its
layer three foreign ally wants
to kill one specific person in a
house and to do that they drop a
£500 guided bomb on that house
knowing it's full of his family
and neighbors.
That's never called violence
against civilians, even when
that's the literal outcome.
Never.
It's sanitized.
It's called a precision strike.
It's framed as a military
necessity.
The civilian deaths are always
always described as regrettable
but justified.
So the whole point of this
language triage, as the source
argues, is to manage our moral
dissonance, the public's
dissonance.
Exactly.
It's for us, the consumers of
the conflict narrative.
The language creates a
comfortable distance.
It allows us to see their
violence as barbaric and ours as
clinical.
It's a tool that lets the state
avoid, as the quote goes,
witnessing our own reflection in
the brutality of it all.
It's a way to maintain the
state's moral monopoly.
That's it.
It's a tool for power
projection.
And it explains why these cycles
of violence just keep going.
Because when you strip away the
labels, you see it's not a fight
between good and evil, it's an
ongoing, brutal competition
between competing authorities.
Which leads us directly into the
core framework of this whole
analysis.
The reason that reflection is so
hard to escape.
The three layers of power.
This is the geometry.
It's the key to understanding
what happens when governance
fails, not just in war zones
but, as we'll see, everywhere.
And this isn't some abstract
political science theory.
The sources say this framework
came directly from people on the
ground, soldiers, diplomats,
journalists observing places
like Iraq or Somalia, places
that were existing on three
completely different operational
realities all at the same time.
Right.
It's a way to make sense of the
chaos.
So let's break them down.
We can start with the one that's
most visible to the outside
world.
Layer one, the official state.
This is the one we all
recognize.
It's the face of the country,
the ministries in the Capitol,
the police in their official
uniforms, the central bank
printing the currency.
It's the national anthem, the
flag flying over the
presidential palace, the
official forms you have to fill
out to get a permit.
It's the authority that has a
seat at the United Nations.
It's the official story of who
is in charge.
But in a lot of these places,
that official story, it's just
that its actual power might not
extend beyond the Capitals Ring
Rd.
And that's a crucial point for
the average person living in a
remote province or even a
neglected urban neighborhood.
Their daily life, their actual
survival, is determined by a
completely different set of
rules and a different set of
rulers.
Which brings us to the second
layer.
Layer 2, the parallel authority.
This is the power structure that
actually governs the street.
This is the reality of
day-to-day life.
We're talking the powerful
tribal shakes, the influential
local clerics, the old families
who've controlled the water
rights or the food smuggling
routes for generations.
It's the people who actually get
things done.
Exactly.
They deal in immediate practical
needs.
If your son gets unjustly
arrested, you don't go to the
corrupt Layer 1 courthouse, you
go to the local Sheikh.
If you need to move goods safely
through a dangerous area, you
pay the local warlord their
phone call.
Their word matters infinitely
more than some stamped piece of
paper from a ministry official
you'll never meet.
And this layer is often ancient.
It existed long before the
current government, and it'll
probably exist long after.
It's deeply rooted in the
culture and the economy of the
place.
And then, particularly in the
last few decades, you have a
third massive force that crashes
into this dynamic.
Layer 3, the foreign power.
The external force This could be
a coalition of invading armies,
UN peacekeepers, a swarm of
international Ng OS, or even
just the intelligence agencies
of a powerful neighboring
country.
And your view of this layer is
entirely transactional, isn't
it?
Depends on what they mean for
you personally.
Completely.
Are they the ones handing out
lucrative reconstruction
contracts and paying salaries in
U.S. dollars?
Or are they the ones conducting
night raids, kicking down doors
and leaving you to write
eulogies for your family
members?
They can be a source of immense
opportunity or immense grief,
often at the same time.
The key here, and what the
sources stress, is that these
three layers don't exist
separately.
They're all operating in the
same space at the same time.
It's this constant, violent,
shifting triangulation of power.
And that framework is the only
way to understand the absolute
payouts that follows a major
foreign intervention, because
layer 3 doesn't just show up and
neatly replace layer one.
It shatters the whole ecosystem.
It completely destabilizes the
existing, even if it was brutal
and dysfunctional, equilibrium
between all three layers.
And this is where that idea of
the power vacuum comes in, when
a superpower, a layer 3 actor,
decides to just knock the legs
out from under an existing layer
one regime, say by invading and
removing a dictator.
The headline back home is tyrant
toppled.
Freedom reigns.
But the operational reality on
the ground, as the sources put
it, is the creation of a
massive, power rich vacuum.
And nature abhors a vacuum, but
politics abhors it even more.
And as we said, vacuums draw
opportunists.
The removal of the central layer
One authority does something
incredibly profound.
It unleashes layer 2.
All those local power Breakers,
the tribal leaders, the
smuggling bosses, the clerics
who are kept in check by the
dictator's secret police,
suddenly the boot is off their
neck.
And they're free to reconfigure
their ambitions.
They can expand.
They can compete.
The competition that follows is
this, this frantic, violent
scramble for power, the sources
say.
It's basically driven by three
distinct types of people who
rush into that vacuum.
OK, what are they?
First you have the remnants of
the old regime, the generals,
the ministers, the party
loyalists who lost everything.
They are fighting desperately to
reclaim their lost power.
They often become the leaders of
the initial insurgency fighting
for restoration.
Then you have the second group.
The opportunists.
These are the people who were
always on the fringes of power
under the old regime, the rival
tribe, the exiled political
opponents, the ambitious local
governor who always wanted more.
They see the chaos as their one
big chance to finally grab The
Maine prize.
And the third group.
This one sounds like the most
unpredictable.
They're the wild cunt, the most
dangerous.
These are the men who, under the
old stable order, never in a
million years imagined they
could hold real power.
But now, with the old rules
gone, they see a path.
These are the people willing to
take.
And I'm quoting insane risks for
a shot at the top.
Because they have nothing to
lose.
Nothing to lose and everything
to gain.
Their ambition is what often
fuels the most radical, most
brutal factions.
And this chaotic, free for all
is the moment of creation.
It's where the new labels are
forged.
How you come out of that scrum
determines what history calls
you.
Exactly.
If your faction wins the street
fight in a key city, you might
consolidate enough power to
become part of the new layer 1.
You become the new police chief,
the new mayor.
If you lose and die, you become
a martyr to your cause.
And if you lose, the political
fight.
But keep your guns and your
followers.
You become the villain, the
terrorist, the criminal that the
new victorious layer one can now
point to as the source of all
the problems.
It's a deeply cynical but
operationally very clear
interpretation of how states are
born from violence.
The difference between a
founding father and a terrorist
leader in that moment can come
down to who won the first few
battles and who got to print the
official letterhead.
What's really, I think,
unsettling about this three
layer model is how, well, how
portable it is.
Once you see that geometry in a
place like Baghdad or Kabul, you
can't Unsee it.
You start to recognize the same
dynamic playing out in places we
would never ever call a conflict
zone.
That's the leap the sources
make, and it's a powerful one.
They argue that in America, for
example, we tend to talk about
our most challenged urban
environments, what the media
often calls inner cities, almost
exclusively in terms of moral
failure.
It's a problem of culture or
character or individual choices.
That's the standard narrative.
Right.
But if you apply this three
layer lens, the picture changes
completely.
You start to see these areas not
as moral failures, but as, and
this is a great quote,
predictable byproducts of
neglected demand and
concentrated opportunity.
It's a structural problem, not
just a moral 1.
So let's try to do that.
Let's map this geometry onto an
American city, say parts of
Chicago or Baltimore, or any
major city with deeply
entrenched poverty and a history
of state neglect.
The mapping is shockingly clean.
Let's start with layer one.
The official government.
That's easy.
It's the mayor giving a press
conference.
The City Council, The police
commissioner, The official court
system, The school board.
It's the state's monopoly on
power, at least on paper.
But in many of these
neighborhoods, that layer one
authority is thin.
It's present, but it's not
always seen as legitimate or
effective.
The police reviewed with
suspicion city services are slow
or non existent.
Which, just like in a failed
state, creates a vacuum, and
that vacuum is filled by layer
2, the parallel authority.
And in this context, that means
what?
The gangs.
It's the gangs, it's the
powerful neighborhood crews,
it's the shot callers who
control the local drug trade.
It's the informal power
structures that actually provide
order and aversion of justice
where layer one has failed.
They're the ones who really
determine how the street
operates, who gets to sell on
which corner, who provides
security for local businesses,
whose cousin gets a job as a
lookout.
They have a system.
It's a violent one, but it's a
system of order.
It is, and then you have the
external force layer 3, the
federal layer.
So the FBI?
The DEA.
Exactly.
The DEA, the FBI, ATF, Homeland
Security, These federal agencies
that roll into the city with
heavy tactical gear, often
operating with a mandate from
Washington DC, not from the
local City Hall.
They come in to disrupt the
local ecosystem.
And just like a foreign
intervention, their arrival can
be incredibly destabilizing.
They might take out a major
Layer 2 leader, a powerful gang
boss, but they don't fix the
underlying conditions.
Not at all.
They don't fix the poverty or
the lack of jobs that created
the vacuum in the 1st place.
So a new, often younger and more
violent Layer 2 actor just rises
up to take the old one's place.
The source material uses this
lens to look at a really hot
button political issue,
sanctuary cities.
Right, which is something we
usually debate in purely immoral
or political terms.
The rhetoric is always about
compassion, about resisting
federal overreach, about local
sovereignty.
It's a political and a moral
statement.
But if you look at it
structurally, operationally, a
city declaring itself a
sanctuary is a layer one
authority making a very clear
statement about who gets to
police.
It's layer 2.
They're saying we'll handle
this, not you.
They're saying we, the local
government, believe we know how
to manage this community better
than you, the federal
government, do.
And the unspoken rationale
behind that is often incredibly
pragmatic.
That phrase from the source.
Better our devils than your
Angel.
Exactly.
The local police, the local
mayor.
They may know that certain
illicit economies are part of
the neighborhood survival, know
which grandmother is having her
rent paid by a nephew who's
involved in the local crew.
They understand the delicate,
complicated social fabric.
And they're afraid that a big
blunt layer three federal raid
will just tear that fabric to
pieces, causing more chaos and
harm than it prevents.
They know that simply
decapitating layer 2 without a
viable replacement doesn't
create a more oral paradise, it
creates a vacuum.
And that core lesson applies
just as much here as it does
anywhere else in an American
city, just like in a Middle
Eastern one.
That vacuum is where you find
the kids with no prospects, no
jobs, no hope from layer one.
And that's where they strap, as
the quote goes, ambition to
adrenaline and just see how far
they can get before they end up
in prison or dead.
The structural cycle is
identical whether the setting is
post war or just post
industrial.
Overlap you're describing it
leads us to what is, for me,
maybe the most provocative
comparison in the entire
analysis.
Yeah.
This is the one that really
challenges our categories.
That the war on drugs is
operationally and structurally
the same kind of fight as the
War on Terror.
Which is a staggering claim
because we are conditioned to
see them as completely different
things. 1 is a law enforcement
problem, the other is a national
security or military problem.
But the sources insist on the
comparison.
Why?
What's the common denominator?
The common denominator is that
both are fights against powerful
non state actors who have
successfully established a form
of parallel governance.
They're doing the state's job.
They are thriving precisely
where the formal state has
failed to meet the three most
basic needs of its citizens, to
feed them, to protect them and
to treat them with a baseline of
respect and dignity.
They are a response to neglected
demand.
And in meeting that demand,
these groups, whether you call
them a cartel or an insurgency,
they provide structure, and in
exchange for that structure,
they demand loyalty, obedience
and risk.
They become, in the words of the
source, the gods of small things
in their territory.
They are the ones who can
actually solve your immediate
life or death problems.
It's worth really spelling out
what those state functions are
that they provide, because this
is where that line between a
government and a criminal
enterprise gets incredibly
blurry.
OK, let's list them.
First, and maybe most important
is financial aid, social
welfare.
These organizations step in to
pay for rent, for a loved ones,
hospital bill for bail money.
They are the social safety net
when the official layer one net
has collapsed or was never there
to begin with.
So they're the emergency loan
office?
They're the emergency loan
office, the welfare office and
the bank all rolled into one
second.
They provide security and a
system of justice.
It might be brutal eye for an
eye justice, but it is swift,
predictable and effective.
And in a place where the
official police are seen as
corrupt, ineffective or an
occupying force, that Layer 2
justice might feel more
legitimate to the local
population.
It often does.
They provide neighborhood
security.
They provide a sense of
belonging.
They'll avenge wrongs done to
their members.
It's conditional, of course.
It's conditional on your
absolute loyalty, but it's a
guarantee.
And the third function.
Social structure and, crucially,
economic opportunity.
For a young person with no
father figure, no Community
Center and no path to a decent
job, a gang or a cartel offers a
fraternity.
It gives them an identity, a
purpose and a clear, albeit
dangerous, ladder to climb for
status and wealth.
So they're providing everything
a state is supposed to provide.
Every single function, Welfare,
justice, security, economic
mobility, a sense of identity,
But they do it, as the analysis
says, with the efficiency and
brutality of a business.
And in a community where the
legal layer one economy only
offers you and I'm quoting
lectures, paperwork and
starvation.
The illegal economy doesn't look
like a moral failure.
It looks like the only ladder
people are willing and able to
climb.
So that's how the perspective
shifts from the outside.
From the layer one perspective
of, say, the US government, a
cartel is a clear existential
threat to stability and the rule
of law.
Absolutely a multibillion dollar
criminal organization, but if
you are an individual living
inside that system with no other
options, the definition changes.
If you don't have a job, the
cartel is an employer.
If the police won't protect you,
the cartel is your insurance
policy.
If you have an idea for a small
business but no bank will give
you a loan, the cartel is your
source of venture capital.
The interest rates are just a
lot.
Higher and the penalties for
default are final, but the
function is the same, and this
is what blurs the lines into
that final, really uncomfortable
definition from the source.
One man's illegal militia is
another man's Volunteer Fire
Department, code enforcement and
welfare office wrapped into one.
Funded by cocaine, fentanyl,
extortion, or ideology, the
function is what commands the
loyalty.
The label applied by outsiders
is irrelevant to the person
whose life is being saved or
sustained by it.
This is the point in the
analysis where, as the sources
themselves point out, a lot of
people just get angry.
Yeah, there's a real resistance
to it.
The idea of a functional
similarity between a state and a
cartel or a soldier and a
terrorist, it feels like an
attack on our whole moral order.
It feels like sacrilege.
And why is that?
What's the root of that anger?
I think it's because we have a
deep, deep need for moral
tidiness.
We want our history and our
politics to be simple.
We need our villains to be pure
evil, you know, with the black
capes and the twirling
mustaches.
And we need our heroes to be
completely pure in both their
methods and their intentions.
But real history and any honest
analysis of power is just never
that clean.
It's never that clean, and the
source material confronts this
discomfort directly, using a
really difficult but necessary
historical example to show why
this Harrow Villain binary so
often fails.
They bring up the Nazi regime in
Germany.
They do, and the point is not to
excuse or mitigate anything.
The moral atrocity of the
Holocaust is absolute and non
negotiable.
We want to remember that regime
only for that.
But that's not the full of how
they achieved and maintained
power.
The analysis points out that the
very same regime also delivered
on promises that resonated
deeply with millions of ordinary
Germans.
They restored full employment
after the Great Depression.
They gave a sense of profound
national pride back to a
population that had been utterly
humiliated by the Treaty of
Versailles and ruined by
hyperinflation.
Again, that fact isn't offered
as a justification.
Not at all.
It's offered as a complication.
It forces us to accept that
legitimacy is a complex and
dangerous thing.
People will support a
government, even a monstrous
one, for reasons that are
practical, emotional and
sometimes horrifying, often all
at once.
It complicates the idea that
people only follow evil out of
ignorance.
It does, and it means we have to
accept that Saints can be
terrifying in their certainty,
that sinners sometimes are the
ones who feed hungry children,
that heroes sometimes commit
massacres to achieve a strategic
goal.
Freedom fighters plant bombs.
Terrorists distribute bread to
win loyalty, the source says.
The robes of a St. and the code
of a tyrant are often cut from
the same cloth.
It's only victory in the passage
of time that lets us neatly
label which was which and the
state the official layer.
One has a massive vested
interest in making sure those
labels are clear and absolute.
It needs to insist that its own
legitimacy is intrinsic,
God-given, and that anyone who
opposes it is inherently unjust.
But if we follow the sources
advice and just step back for a
second, if we look at the state
not morally, but purely
structurally, purely by its
architecture and function.
You arrive at the most stunning
conclusion in the entire
analysis that the.
State itself structurally
resembles the most efficient
cartel ever built.
Now hold on.
I have to push back on that.
That sounds like pure cynicism.
I mean, a democratic state
provides public schools, it
builds roads, it has courts and
accountability.
A cartel just murders its rivals
and sells drugs.
Surely there's a fundamental
difference.
And the sources would agree
there's a difference in state
admission, in ideology, and
hopefully an outcome.
But they insist that if you look
only at the raw mechanisms of
power and control, the parallels
are undeniable and staggering.
OK, so let's break down those
parallel functions.
What are the mechanisms?
1st A monopoly on violence.
Both the state and the
sophisticated cartel claim the
exclusive right to use force
within their territory to
enforce their will.
Any other use of force is, by
their definition, illegal.
OK, that's fair. 2nd mandatory
revenue collection.
The state calls it taxation.
It takes a cut of every
transaction in exchange for
providing services and
protection.
And the cartel calls it tribute
or protection money.
They take their cut in exchange
for providing their own version
of services and protection.
And in both systems, if you
refuse to pay, men with guns
will eventually show up at your
door. 3rd, and this is critical,
both the state and the cartel
are the sole arbiters of what is
legal and what is criminal
within their sphere of
influence.
The state uses its authority to
give medals to its killers,
calling them soldiers or police
officers.
And it uses that same authority
to put other killers who used
force without its permission in
a cage for the rest of their
lives, calling them criminals.
So the argument, the really
radical argument, is that the
conflict between the state and
these parallel authorities isn't
a moral crusade, it's a business
dispute.
It's a competition for monopoly
control.
The state layer one doesn't
arrest a layer two shot caller
because he uses violence, it
arrests him because he uses
unauthorized violence.
It arrests him because he's
running his own unauthorized tax
system and because he commands a
loyalty from the local
population that hasn't been
approved to the proper channels.
It's a fight over who gets to be
the sole provider of governance.
And if the state actually
provides the security, the jobs
and the justice the people need,
its position as layer one is
secure.
If it doesn't, a layer 2 entity,
whether it's an ideological
militia or a profit driven
cartel, will step in, perform
those state functions, and in
doing so earn a very real, very
powerful operational legitimacy
on the ground.
It is absolutely critical that
we state here, just as the
source analysis does repeatedly,
that this structural
interpretation is not a plea for
moral relativism.
It's not an argument for
shrugging our shoulders and
saying all violence is the same.
No, absolutely not.
This is a cold, hard look at the
architecture of power.
It's not an endorsement of any
of the players because the human
cost of this constant layer
dance for power is it's immense.
It's immediate and it's brutal.
Children die in this dance.
Families are shattered.
Addiction hollows out entire
communities.
Drone strikes can erase a human
body so completely that a
family's grief has to imagine
the bones of their loved one.
Because there's nothing left to
bury.
The suffering is the constant,
but to understand that suffering
and maybe to one day have a
chance of lessening it, we have
to understand the mechanics that
keep producing it.
One man's savior is another
man's tyrant.
One soldiers precision strike is
another family's empty chair at
the kitchen table.
The outrage people feel is
always real.
The grief is always real.
But the categories we use,
terrorist, soldier, criminal,
freedom fighter, martyr, those
are always, always negotiated.
They're defined by whoever is
currently in control of the most
powerful layer 1 mechanism.
The semantics are always for
sale, and the price is often
paid in blood.
This structural view just forces
us to admit that the very labels
we cling to for moral comfort
are often just the authorized
tools of power.
The sources leave us with this
one final, incredibly haunting
observation.
It's one that ties the foreign
and the domestic, the war zone
and the city street all
together.
It's about a strange kind of
symmetry.
It says that a major cartel
funeral with all its ceremony
and a formal military memorial
for a soldier killed in action.
They share a strange, rhyming
grief.
In both ceremonies, you have a
community mourning someone who
they believe down to the very
core of their being, died doing
what was right, what was
necessary for their people, for
their tribe, for their family.
That absolute, unshakable
conviction in their own
righteousness.
Yeah, it exists on all sides.
Sides.
And that, maybe, is the most
disturbing part of this entire
structure.
Which brings us to the final
thought.
The source material leaves us
with the question we want to
leave with you.
Should the fact that both
groups, the official state
soldier and the member of the
parallel authority, are so
equally and fiercely convinced
of their own moral
righteousness, should that
unsettle us more than the simple
fact that they shoot at each
other?
It suggests that the deepest
problem might not be the
violence itself, but the
absolute, uncompromising
certainty on every side that
fuels it layer.
By layer, our discussion today,
well, it centers on the source
materials, exploration of
political legitimacy, power
structures, and the raw
functional truth that's kind of
hidden within that old cliche
One man's freedom fighter is
another man's terrorist.
We're really exploring the
unsettling idea that this is
less of a paradox and more of a
a structural blueprint of modern
conflict.
Right.
And the structure we are
examining, this simultaneous
existence of the state, what it
calls layer one and these
parallel authorities layer 2, it
really forces us to rethink how
political legitimacy is actually
established and maybe more
importantly, maintained.
Absolutely.
So the central question we have
to address is this does the
material structural analysis of
power fundamentally reduce
political legitimacy to a purely
transactional outcome, something
negotiated solely through force
and opportunity?
Or does the state's claim to a
monopoly on authorized violence
maintain some kind of crucial,
non negotiable functional
distinction?
And I'll be arguing that despite
the moral ambiguities and and
the often egregious hypocrisy of
state action, the successful
enforcement of authorized verse
unauthorized violence, that
remains the defining functional
mechanism of governance.
And I think this mechanism
creates a difference that you
can't entirely reduce to just
semantics or transactional
outcomes.
And I'm going to argue the other
side that the structural and
functional overlaps revealed by
this 3 layers of power model,
they render those moral and
legal categories inherently
ambiguous.
I think in this environment,
legitimacy is fundamentally
negotiated, it's transactional
and at the end of the day it's
defined by the victor who gets
to write the history.
OK, let's unpack the
architecture then.
My position really begins with
this idea that the structural
equivalence between layer one
and layer 2 is well, it's an
operational truth.
I mean, when you look at the
modern state at layer one, it
structurally resembles what the
material calls the most
efficient cartel ever built.
And that's not just a
provocative statement, it's a
functional description.
The state defines who is a
soldier and who is a criminal.
It claims and usually enforces a
physical monopoly on violence.
And crucially, it takes a cut of
every single transaction.
OK, I can acknowledge the state
acts like a cartel, but what
makes it efficient?
I mean cartels extort states
text.
Why is that distinction merely
semantic?
Because the state has developed
these incredibly advanced tools
of extraction and enforcement
that layer 2 can only dream of.
It's more efficient because it
can seize assets legally, it can
enforce collection globally
through international treaties,
it prints the very currency that
layer 2 transactions rely on,
and it can leverage the threat
of legal imprisonment for non
compliance.
So these layer 2 authorities,
gangs, militias, cartels, they
essentially replicate the
structure.
They step into the vacuum left
by the state and become the gods
of small things.
They provide protection,
adjudicate disputes, manage
welfare, pay rent or offer
loans.
These are all services that meet
a genuine demand for governance.
So governance is just utility
then, regardless of the uniform?
Precisely if the function of
providing security and structure
is fulfilled, whether it's by
forms and fees or threats and
extortion, the underlying
reality is the same.
Legitimacy becomes a
transactional commodity based on
provision.
The semantics you know who is
the hero and who is the villain
are, as the material says,
always for sale when violence is
the ultimate currency.
That's a compelling, I'll admit.
I'll be it bleak structural
reading, but the legal framework
that layer one enforces, that is
the key distinction I want to
focus on.
We agree the analysis of modern
conflict is deeply
uncomfortable, but layer 2
authorities are pursued and
eliminated by layer one not
because they use force, but
because they use unauthorized
force and collect taxes without
permission.
But again, that just sounds like
the strongest man getting to
define the rule book after he's
already won the fistfight.
Well, it is the strongest force
defining the rule book, yes, but
that successful definition
creates a necessary functional
difference.
The material details the
anatomical reality of modern
conflict.
It describes forces like the
seals and the SASA, centralized
professional army killing a
distributed ecology of
grievance.
This is not a clash of equals.
The power the state holds is the
institutional ability to assign
value and consequence to
violence.
They can label a guided bomb
drop on a populated St.
Precision necessity.
Regrettable but justified.
I mean, this is a form of
institutional coercion that
layer 2 simply cannot replicate
on a national scale.
And I agree that layer 2 lacks
that institutional capacity, but
only because layer one is
actively denying it to them,
usually with overwhelming
kinetic force.
But the longevity of layer One's
power rests on its legal
infrastructure.
The system defines who gets
medals and who was incarcerated
for life.
And furthermore, if layer 2 does
succeed in challenging layer
one, let's say a cartel
achieving some quasi state
status, it almost always
requires the alignment of layer
3 and that layer three.
Whether it's an external
intervention like NATO, federal
agencies like the DEA, or a
regional proxy power, it's what
validates or invalidates the
legitimacy of the challengers.
In the absence of that, Layer 3
validation ensures Layer 2
remains A localized existential
threat to the state, but not a
functional long term
replacement.
OK, let's delve into the anatomy
of conflict, because I think
this is where the state's claim
distinction really reveals
itself as a negotiation.
The material is unflinching on
this.
In the Global War on Terror,
many of the opponents who were
killed were legally
noncombatants.
They were civilians who chose to
fight.
They weren't uniformed or
conscripted.
They were civilians fighting
soldiers.
It is a devastating definition,
soldiers killing civilians who
act like soldiers.
It's more than devastating.
It's structurally revealing.
The state engages in what you
could call linguistic triage,
calling them insurgent,
extremist or narco terrorist.
This language is designed to
obscure the reality that under
international law, the victim
was legally a civilian.
The state uses these labels to
create a moral distance, a
justification really to avoid
witnessing its own reflection.
The state, the most efficient
cartel, simply defines its own
unavoidable violent acts as
necessary and its opponents
necessary violent acts is
illegal.
The distinction is defined by
the power of the labeler, not
the inherent morality or
function of the ACT itself.
I agree that language is the
state's most powerful tool for
self justification.
I absolutely do.
However, the operational reality
that is rooted in the state's
functional claim to authority is
different, and that matters
profoundly for the structure.
An army has a verifiable chain
of command.
It has rules of engagement, a
national mandate, the
distributed opposition.
It lacks that they are fighting
to create a parallel governance
and that struggle over who
controls the legal apparatus of
force itself.
The very structure that dictates
who wins medals is a functional
fight, not just a semantic 1.
But the legal apparatus only
matters if it can fill the
vacuum, and that is exactly
where layer 2 governance proves
its transactional legitimacy.
You just have to look at the
vacuum effect and destabilize
zones like Iraq or neglected
areas within functioning states.
The material frames these
outcomes not as intrinsic moral
failures, but as predictable
byproducts of neglected demand
and concentrated opportunity.
When layer one collapses or
neglects its fundamental
responsibilities, layer 2 steps
in.
I acknowledge that the market
abhors a vacuum, and layer 2
fills it with astonishing speed.
Exactly.
Take the example of cartels or
local militias.
They become the primary
employers, the informal Social
Security, and the venture
capital source for entire
populations that the legitimate
economy just ignores when layer
one refuses to adjudicate a land
dispute or when a family needs
quick money for a medical
emergency.
Layer 2 is the Supreme Court and
the bank.
Its ruling is immediate, it's
credible, and it's enforced by
credible threat.
This demonstrates that
legitimacy is strictly
transactional.
Layer 2 provides provision and
immediate security in exchange
for loyalty and an acceptance of
risk.
Utility is the currency of
governance.
That's a compelling analysis of
utility, but I have to question
the functional equivalence based
on the nature of that
transaction and its
consequences.
I agree.
The illegal economy often offers
the only ladder available, but
layer one, for all its faults,
funds its extraction.
It's taxation by creating a
system that theoretically
provides public goods.
Broadly, Layer 2 provides
structure with the brutality of
a business and it's funded
directly by extortion by human
trafficking and the wholesale
distribution of destructive
substances like fentanyl.
But all governance is
extractive, and the history of
layer one is rife with brutality
and destruction in the name of
development.
Layer one is funded by income
tax, by bonds, and historically
by colonial extraction.
Layer 2 is funded by illicit
extraction.
Both are mandatory contributions
enforced by violence or the
threat of it.
The functional difference is 1
of scale and legality, not
foundational morality.
Well, I think the functional
distinction lies in the negative
externalities.
Layer 2's governance, rooted as
it is in illicit means, it
destabilizes the very community
it claims to protect through
addiction and perpetual
violence.
Furthermore, the material makes
it clear that Layer one
agencies, the DEA, the FBI, the
military, they have the ability
to cross Layer 2 boundaries and
dismantle those structures.
Layer 2 cannot raid the DEA.
That structural asymmetry means
layer one always retains the
ultimate functional legal power
to authorize the force used to
collect those extractions and
enforce its borders.
Your reliance on layer one's
ultimate course of capacity,
though, it forces us back to the
heart of this moral ambiguity.
If we accept the structural
equivalence of extraction, then
we have to accept the complexity
of historical judgment.
The source material presses this
point.
Saints are sometimes terrifying
sinners, sometimes feed
children.
History is indeed profoundly
untidy.
We can cite the example of the
regime that gassed millions but
also restored employment and
national pride to a shattered
nation.
The intent is to show that
fixed, clean moral categories,
they fail under rigorous
historical scrutiny.
Legitimacy, therefore, is
fundamentally contingent.
It's assigned after the fact by
the victorious storyteller.
If the insurgents win, they get
statues and are declared freedom
fighters.
If they lose, they are declared
terrorists and executed.
That is the definition of
transactional legitimacy.
The outcome dictates the
morality, not the other way
around.
I'm not convinced by that line
of reasoning, because it ignores
the constraints the material
itself provides.
While fixed categories certainly
fail, the analysis explicitly
includes a disclaimer.
None of this is a plea for moral
relativism or for shrugging
indifference.
The outrage, the grief, the
palpable suffering, shattered
families, the drone strikes that
literally erase bodies, The
widespread addiction.
These remain concrete realities,
regardless of what label we
apply to the perpetrator.
The outrage is absolutely real,
but the system designed to judge
that outrage is biased from the
start.
Yes, it is biased.
But the fact that both sides,
the cartel figure and the
military soldier, they both
mourn someone who died believing
they were doing the right thing,
that should unsettle us.
But it shouldn't convince us
that the fundamental
institutional power to authorize
violence is irrelevant.
The state's ability to create
the system that judges those
acts is the ultimate functional
distinction.
Our focus should be on the
impact of these negotiated
categories on the people who
experience the real
consequences.
The system dictates who can
legally drop the bomb and walk
away with a medal, and who uses
force and receives life in a
maximum security cell.
That power defines the
consequences.
That power, however, is rooted
solely in capacity and
historical success, not in any
inherent moral superiority.
And that is the structuralist
argument.
Capacity defines the definition.
But the architecture of Layer
one allows for a stability, a
scale, and a longevity that
Layer 2, by its unauthorized
nature and its perpetual
criminal status, simply cannot
sustain without constant
external challenge.
The state's claim to
authorization is not just a
narrative, it's the structural
element that ensures its
durability.
This has been a rigorous and I
think a very necessary
dissection of the source
materials challenging
architecture.
My position remains that the
functional analysis of the three
layers and the structural
equivalence between the state
and parallel authorities.
It reveals that legitimacy is
fundamentally negotiated,
transactional, and ultimately
defined by the victor who
successfully enforces their
narrative.
The claim to authorize violence
is the state's most powerful
tool of negotiation, but it is
not an intrinsic, non negotiable
truth.
And I maintain that while states
often act precisely like the
most efficient cartel, the power
to define that authorization, to
enforce it institutionally, and
to scale it nationally remains
the central functional
difference.
Layer 1 controls the mechanism
of lasting legal power, the
power to give medals or maximum
security, and that institutional
difference keeps layer two in
the status of a perpetual
challenger, never a true peer.
The distinction between
authorized and unauthorized
force remains the most defining
mechanism of modern governance.
I think the enduring value of
this analysis, as the source
material makes clear, is that it
forces this uncomfortable
realization that the outrage
over violence is always real and
palpable, even as the.
Categories we used to define
that violence, whether
terrorist, freedom fighter or
precision strike, are always
subject to negotiation and
change based on power dynamics.
Indeed, this discussion confirms
the necessity of rigorously
challenging the moral
certainties that language
imposes on conflict.
The piece.
We're looking at today one man's
freedom fighter, another man's
terrorist.
Really gets into how that cliche
is an operational truth, using a
three layer model of power to
show how legitimacy gets
negotiated.
It's a sharp piece.
It cuts right to the bone of
modern conflict and control.
You know why those definitions
shift depending on who's holding
the gun.
Our job today is to help sharpen
that structure and make the
emotional punch land even
harder.
Absolutely.
And looking at the model itself,
I think there's a huge
opportunity right away.
So the material establishes this
really compelling framework, the
three layers of power, right?
The official state, the parallel
authority, and the foreign or
federal power.
But the narrative would be so
much stronger with a deeper look
at the functional symbiosis or
even the strategic tolerance
between layer one and layer 2.
That's the perfect place to
start.
That's the Nexus we need to
explore.
Yeah.
It is right now the framework
sort of emphasizes the idea that
layer 2, the parallel authority,
it only steps in where layer one
fails.
Right, it's that nature, Aboorza
vacuum model.
The state falls apart, so the
cartel or the militia steps in
to manage food routes or jobs or
whatever it is.
And that model, it's, it's a
little too neat.
It is.
The weakness is that it frames
the relationship purely as this
failure vacuum scenario, and
that just misses the
intentionality.
You know, it overlooks the
political engineering that
happens when Layer 1 isn't just
helpless or collapsed, but is
strategically managing its own
limited resources.
Exactly.
So we need to introduce this
element of of deliberate
negotiation or calculated
alliances, even between the
official state and the parallel
authority.
Yes, we need to challenge that
simple failure model and show
how layer 2 authorities
sometimes perform layer one
functions because the state
chooses to let them.
It's outsourcing.
Because some of those functions
are politically toxic.
I mean the official state layer
one, it might not want its
fingerrints on controlling, say,
certain supply chains or
enforcing a certain kind of
local brutality, but it
absolutely needs the stability
that those layer two groups
provide.
O let's get concrete on that.
We need to detail some instances
where layer one officials might
tolerate specific smuggling
bosses or or local shot callers
from layer 2, right?
As long as those figures, you
know, guarantee a reduction in
lower level St. violence, or
they keep specific supply chains
open, that totally changes layer
one from a victim into a a
calculated manager of delegated
illegal power.
And then from the other side,
the parallel authority, whether
it's a gang or a cartel, is
sophisticated enough to play its
part.
They do this by mimicking the
very bureaucracy they're
supposedly fighting against.
Oh yeah.
We should expand on how they use
these pseudo legal structures
like enforced contracts,
protection schemes, internal
dispute resolution, all things
that, you know, actively
replicate the bureaucratic
brutality of the state.
It shows they're not just
filling a void with chaos,
they're actually replicating
systems of governance, complete
with penalties and enforced
loyalty.
It's why they stick around.
And this ties so perfectly into
the part about sanctuary cities.
It's already a great example of
layer one resisting Layer 3.
The feds, sure, but we can link
it explicitly to this idea of
strategic tolerance.
That declaration isn't just
about ethics.
It's also about Layer one
officials wanting to better
control or leverage their
existing Layer 2 structures.
The piece already has has that
brilliant line.
Better our devils than your
angels.
Exactly.
We just need to make sure the
analysis fully supports that
strategic calculus show that the
state is preserving its right to
manage its own parallel
authority, not just, you know,
protecting some abstract idea of
autonomy.
It makes the whole dynamic so
much more unsettling and
sophisticated.
It stops being a simple
hierarchy and becomes this
really complex negotiated web of
shared power.
And Speaking of unsettling that,
that brings us to the weight of
all these definitions.
So look, the closing segment
powerfully articulates this
moral discomfort.
You know that Saints can be
terrifying, sinners can feed
children.
Categories are always
negotiated.
But integrating this thematic
tension earlier will just raise
the narrative stakes through the
entire piece.
The moral core of this thing is
undeniable, and that conclusion,
it hits so hard.
The problem is really one of
pacing all the most visceral
stuff.
The drone strikes, erasing
bodies, the empty chairs at the
table from addiction.
That line about the rhyming
grief of a cartel funeral and a
military memorial.
It's almost all saved for the
last two paragraphs.
And the weakness there is that
it risks making the moral
ambiguity feel like a like a
philosophical punchline, a deep
thought at the end.
Yeah, a conclusion.
Right.
Instead of the core ethical
challenge that should be driving
the political anatomy from the
very beginning, it's like we
dissect the machine first, and
only then do we look at the
people that shoot up.
We need to merge those things.
We need to flip that
relationship entirely.
The trauma has to inform the
dissection.
So the suggestion is introduce
the human stakes right after you
establish that initial
operational truth.
Those unsettling outcomes, the
shattered families, the missing
bones, the empty kitchen chairs,
They should be used to ground
abstract concepts like
linguistic triage.
Because the pain of that triage
is never abstract, right?
It's a specific missing face at
a dinner table.
Always.
So when the piece defines the
anatomy of modern conflict, that
bit about soldiers killing
civilians who are acting like
soldiers, we should immediately
follow it up.
Link the state's language.
You know, precision, necessity,
regrettable but justified.
Link that directly to the
immediate, visceral feeling of
grief that makes the cost of the
word itself immediate.
And that gives the whole
critique an ethical pulse from
start to finish.
We can weave in that idea that
the outrage is always real much
earlier, maybe when it describes
how layer 2 entities become
these gods of small things,
providing insurance or capital,
but with much faster penalties.
That's a critical connection.
You're linking the transactional
benefits of layer 2 directly to
the moral ambiguity of why it
even exists.
You're showing the reader that
the system is built on these
heartbreaking sacrifices
happening in real time, not just
in the epilogue.
And that observation that a
cartel funeral and a military
memorial share a strange,
rhyming grief instead of saving
it for the end, It would be a
perfect midpoint transition.
Oh, that's good.
Use it to bridge the global
conflict analysis to the
domestic application.
It signals to the reader that
this uncomfortable moral parody
isn't just a theory.
It's structural.
It's immediate.
That one small structural change
would make the piece so much
more engaging.
Because the reader is constantly
confronted with the human weight
of these definitions, the
analysis never gets a chance to
become sterile before you hit
them with that emotional payoff.
Which I think leads us very
naturally to our third major
focus, which is really about
enhancing the domestic
application of this model.
So the piece makes this really
creative leap, applying the
three layer model to places like
Baltimore and Chicago, but the
structural parallels between
layer 3 abroad, the occupiers,
and layer three at home like the
DEA or FBI, they could be made
way more explicit and
actionable.
Yeah, the domestic application
is strong when it's defining
layer 2.
It really nails how gangs
provide services, the jobs,
fraternity insurance.
It does.
But the weakness is that it
doesn't fully develop how the
operational philosophy of the
federal layer 3 structurally
mirrors the destabilizing
actions of the foreign layer
three.
It asserts the comparison
between the war on drugs and the
War on Terror, but the mechanism
of destabilization feels a
little underdeveloped on the
domestic side.
Right.
The foreign intervention is
shown to disrupt the power
balance, which frees up layer 2
to reconfigure their ambitions
create vacuums.
All that.
Opportunism.
Yeah.
We need to see that same
mechanical destabilizing impact
applied explicitly to federal
intervention here at home.
It's not just about policing,
it's about structural
disruption.
Exactly.
So the suggestion here is to.
Strengthen that domestic
analogy.
Detail the specific ways federal
intervention operates like a
foreign power, you know,
enforcing mandates from
somewhere far away,
destabilizing the local power
balance and inadvertently
empowering rival Layer 2
factions.
Just like the coalition did in
Iraq.
You know, remove one dictator,
you get 10 warlords.
So we need to show the
operational similarities, like
what are the parallels between
counterterrorism tactics used
globally and the deployment of
tactical gear and special units
by the DEA or FBI in American
cities?
Yes.
We should focus on how those
actions are really targeting
unauthorized force and
unapproved loyalty, maybe even
more than they're targeting a
reduction in actual harm.
It's about maintaining the
state's monopoly on violence,
even if it makes things more
violent locally in the short
term.
And you have to elaborate on the
direct consequences.
What happens when the Federal
Layers intervention creates a
localized vacuum by taking out a
layer 2 liter?
It creates chaos.
It leads to intense internal
conflict among, as the tech
says, kids with no prospects
strapping ambition to
adrenaline.
I mean, that's a perfect echo of
what happens after a regime
change abroad.
Show the reader that the method
of intervention is what causes
the chaos, regardless of the
stated goal.
And then finally, we should lean
into the text.
Powerful assertion that the
state is like the most efficient
cartel ever built.
Give specific examples of how
the federal layer 3 applies its
monopoly on violence and its
ability to tax without
permission at home.
Things like civil forfeiture,
prod federal mandates, the
ability to operate totally
outside of local politics.
If that analogy holds, then the
federal government has to be
shown acting like a supremely
powerful, legally sanctioned
Layer 2, not just an outside
police force.
Connecting those dots
structurally makes the
comparison truly operational.
It shows that whether it's the
foreign layer 3IN Magdad or the
federal layer 3 in Baltimore,
the mechanism for control and
disruption follows the same
violent pattern.
You replace one unapproved power
structure with approved, but
often just as volatile
competition.
This is an incredibly robust
piece of writing.
I mean, it tackles one of the
most frustrating moral and
political riddles of our time.
And the three main areas for
refinement are, I think, clear
and they're all interconnected.
So just to recap the actionable
steps here, first explicitly
analyze the strategic tolerance
and political engineering
between the official state layer
one and the parallel authority
layer 2.
Move beyond that simple failure
vacuum model and really show the
intentionality behind the
outsourcing of power. 2nd
Integrate that powerful moral
ambiguity, that devastating
human cost much earlier in the
narrative.
Let the visceral sticks, the
missing bodies, the rhyming
grief.
Let that drive the structural
analysis instead of just serving
as the philosophical conclusion.
And 3rd, strengthen the domestic
analogy.
Detail the structural
similarities between foreign and
federal intervention Layer 3 by
focusing on how federal action
functionally destabilizes local
power balances through that
targeted external enforcement.
These are really specific,
actionable suggestions.
They're all aimed at maximizing
the impact and the internal
logic of an already compelling
thesis.
If you implement these, the
critique will shift from being a
powerful observation to an
unforgettable argument.
We'd really encourage you to
send your revised book.
Back in for a while, it gets
trotted out anytime a
conversation about conflict gets
a little too uncomfortable.
One man's freedom fighter is
another man's terrorist.
Exactly.
And most of the time people say
with this little shrug, you
know, like it's just some
cynical Hallmark card wisdom we
can look at and then put away.
But the sources we're diving
into today, they are really
insistent on this point.
They argue that this isn't just
a paradox, it's it's a blunt
operational truth about how the
world actually functions.
And that's our mission for this
deep dive.
We're going to take that saying
completely seriously, because
when you do, you start to see
the, well, the real architecture
of how power and violence are
negotiated.
And we should be upfront here.
It's a deeply uncomfortable
thing to look at.
It is because it shows you that
legitimacy isn't some fixed
moral thing handed down from on
high.
Not at all.
Legitimacy is it's negotiated
minute by minute.
It's hammered out by who has the
biggest gun, who controls the
food, who can offer revenge or
opportunity, and maybe most
importantly, by the stories
people tell themselves about why
they deserve to win.
OK, let's unpack all of that.
And I think we have to jump
straight into the most, let's
call it radioactive example in
our sources.
The global War on Terror.
Yeah, because it immediately
throws this fundamental
asymmetry of modern conflict
into sharp relief.
And we have to start with the
legal definitions.
Think about all the people
America targeted and killed over
the last two decades.
Afghanistan.
Iraq.
Somalia.
All over.
Right.
Every single person on the
receiving end of a drone strike
or a raid was, by a strict legal
definition, a civilian.
That's a strong claim.
I mean, people here insurgent,
militant.
So what do you mean by civilian?
It means they weren't
conscripted soldiers, they
weren't wearing a state issued
uniform or fighting under a
recognized national flag.
They were, you know, farmers,
shopkeepers, unemployed kids who
chose to join a 'cause they
chose to pick up a gun.
OK, so now contrast that with
the other side, the force sent
to hunt them.
Well, these weren't farmers who
decided to fight.
These were the most
professional, most highly
specialized soldiers that
modernity has ever created.
You're talking about tier one
special forces.
Exactly.
JSOC's teams, Navy Seals, the
British way.
These are highly trained, state
funded professionals paid by
sovereign states to neutralize
people those same states have
labeled as threats.
So the whole picture of modern
war isn't to armies in clean
lines, it's something else.
It's what the sources call an
army and a distributed ecology
of grievance.
Wow.
It's professional soldiers
killing civilians who are acting
like soldiers.
And this is where the asymmetry
becomes total, because the state
controls the language, and
language is the ultimate tool
for triage.
Triage is the perfect word.
It's how we decide who gets
moral consideration, right?
The sources really dig into how
we use these words.
Sort of avoid looking in the
mirror.
Absolutely.
The label we apply is all about
whose interests are being
served.
So if a civilian, a 20 year old
kid, detonates a bomb in a
market, we all immediately agree
that's terrorism?
It's the highest moral
condemnation possible.
Right, but what if that same
kid, or maybe his brother, fires
a rifle out of patrol that, say,
just bulldozed his uncle's farm?
The label shifts.
Now he's an insurgent, a
fighter, maybe still a terrorist
depending on the headline.
See.
But notice what happens when the
force is reversed, when the
state uses its most advanced
weapon to drop a guided bomb on
a house to kill one single
person who joined the wrong
banner.
We call that a precision strike,
a necessity.
Regrettable but justified.
It's a linguistic sleight of
hand, and the moral weight just
depends on who's holding the
dictionary.
And to understand why that
reflection keeps popping up, we
have to look at the structure
underneath it all.
This is where the sources bring
in this framework.
The three layers of power.
They argue that in any contested
area, these three layers are
operating at the same time.
OK, so let's make this concrete.
The sources used post invasion
Iraq as the main example.
What were the layers there?
OK, so layer one is the official
state, the government on paper?
Ministries, police, the flag,
the guys giving press
conferences.
Exactly.
They have the official seal of
approval, but in a place like
Iraq after 2003, they often had
very little actual power on the
ground.
So who did that?
Must be layer 2.
Layer 2, The parallel authority.
This is where the real power is.
These are the men whose phone
calls mattered more than any
official government decree.
The sheiks, The clerics.
The tribal leaders, the
smuggling bosses, the families
who controlled the water and
food routes, they were the ones
who actually ran things
day-to-day.
And the third layer.
Layer 3 is the foreign power, in
this case the coalition, the
occupiers.
They're the ones with the
fighter jets and the big
military bases.
They have the ultimate
firepower.
And all three are there at once,
all competing, sometimes
colliding.
Constantly, and this is where
the sources get really sharp.
Foreign intervention doesn't
just replace layers 1 and 2.
It destabilizes them.
It creates a vacuum.
When the Coalition came in, they
chopped the head off of layer
one and sort of pushed layer 3
down.
But in doing so they knocked the
legs out from under layer 2.
They broke the old equilibrium.
And power vacuums.
They always get filled.
And not by the most noble
people.
It's predictable.
You get the men who just lost
power trying to claw it back.
You get the guys who were almost
in power, the mid level
operators making a grab for it.
And then you get the people who
never even dreamed of having
power.
The kids, the young men taking
absolutely insane risks and the
sources are so clear on this.
It's all the same pool of
people.
Some become villains, some
become the new US backed mayors
and some become martyrs.
That framework, the three
layers, the vacuum, once you see
it, you can't Unsee it.
And it's not just over there.
That's the unsettling part.
The sources draw this Direct
Line, saying America talks about
its own inner cities the way it
talks about foreign conflict
zones.
As moral failures, failures of
character or culture.
Instead of seeing them as
predictable results of a layered
power structure where the
official state has failed.
OK, so let's apply the model.
Take a city like Baltimore or
Chicago.
Layer One.
That's easy.
The mayor, City Council, the
police commissioner, the
official government.
And layer 2, the parallel
authority on the streets.
This is the crucial one.
It's the cruise, the gangs, the
shop callers.
They're the ones who really
decide who gets a job, who's
protected and who gets hurt for
crossing a line.
They run the Gray economy.
They provide the immediate
security.
And layer 3, the foreign power
in this analogy, that would be
the federal government.
Precisely.
The DEA, The FBI, Homeland
Security.
They roll in with their tactical
gear to enforce federal laws,
often completely ignoring the
delicate, violent balance of
Layer 2.
Which gives a whole new meaning
to something like a sanctuary
city debate.
The public rhetoric is all about
compassion.
But structurally, it's a fight
over who gets to police Layer 2.
The local government is
essentially telling the federal
government layer three, these
are our problems.
We understand them better than
you do.
The unspoken part is better our
devils than your angels.
Because if you just come in and
wipe out layer 2 without
replacing it with a trusted
functional layer one, you don't
get peace, you get another
vacuum.
And that's where, as the sources
put it, kids with no prospects
strap ambition to adrenaline.
Suddenly, the war on drugs
starts to look operationally
identical to the War on Terror.
They're fighting the same thing,
non state actors who build a
parallel government where the
official one has failed to feed,
protect or respect people.
A cartel, like a militia,
provides structure.
It comes with obedience and
risk, but it's structure.
And that's where the cartel
becomes this paradoxical
benefactor.
I mean, to the US government,
it's a massive threat.
Of course.
But if you're a citizen living
inside that system, a cartel can
be a job when there are no jobs.
It can be a fraternity when you
have no family.
It can be your insurance, your
protection.
The gods of small things, as the
source material calls them.
Yes, they're the ones handling
rent, covering hospital bills,
paying bail.
They are performing the
functions of the state.
They just fund it with cocaine
and extortion.
And that ambiguity is what makes
us so uncomfortable.
We want our villains to be
villains, full stop.
We want clean lines, but the
sources just demolish that idea.
The summary is so powerful.
One man's illegal militia is
another's Volunteer Fire
Department, code enforcement and
welfare office all wrapped into
one.
And history is full of his
complication.
We want to believe evil
announces itself clearly.
But it rarely does.
The sources use that incredibly
tough example of the German
regime in the 30s, the same
regime that built gas chambers
also simultaneously restored
employment and a sense of
national pride to a completely
broken country.
Which doesn't redeem the horror
for a second.
Not at all.
But it complicates everything.
It forces you to see that
tyranny can show up promising
competence, that sinners
sometimes feed children, that
the coat of the tyrant and the
robe of the Saint are often on
the same hook.
And that leads us all the way
back to the state itself, Layer
one, if you look at it from far
enough away.
It starts to look structurally
like the most successful cartel
ever built.
It claims a monopoly on violence
in the territory.
And it takes a cut of every
single transaction.
We call it taxes.
It uses force to maintain its
existence.
So the state arrests these
parallel leaders not because
they use force.
The state uses force all the
time.
It arrests them because they use
unauthorized force, they command
loyalty, and they tax without
permission.
It's a fight over who owns the
copyright on governance.
But even as we talk about this
geometry of power, we have to
remember the human cost.
This isn't just a thought
experiment.
No children die, families are
shattered.
And the sources point out this
this strange and awful symmetry
that a military memorial for a
soldier and a cartel funeral for
a sicario share a strange,
rhyming grief.
The loss is just as real.
So bringing it all home, right
One soldiers precision strike is
another family's empty chair at
the dinner table.
And the categories we use,
terrorist, freedom fighter,
patriot, criminal, they're
always up for negotiation.
The semantics are for sale and
blood is the currency.
The most unsettling truth from
all this for me isn't just that
these groups are shooting at
each other.
No, it's something deeper.
It's the fact that both groups,
the state sanctioned soldier and
the leader of the parallel
authority, are absolutely, 100%
convinced of their own
righteousness.
They both truly believe they are
doing right by their people.
That shared, unwavering
conviction, that's the engine
driving this whole architecture
of power.
And maybe the real question for
you to think about is what that
means for the next conflict or
the next power vacuum that's
already taking shape, maybe even
in your own community.
We'll leave you with that
thought for now.